[musique]
Jean-Baptiste Rivoir, bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Euh ouais, moi j'ai voilà, j'ai 58 ans,
je suis je suis un peu à Algéra
français. J'ai un peu grandi en Algérie,
je suis un peu français aussi. Euh, j'ai
fait 30 ans de journalisme. Euh,
toujours un peu en mode résistance. Je
suis un peu énervé contre les
injustices, tu vois. J'ai passé 10 ans
avec une caméra sur l'épaule et 15 20
ans à faire de l'investigation. Et
j'aime pas les prêtes à penser, j'aime
pas les trucs pas pas sûr, j'aime pas
les les propagandes, quoi. En fait,
surtout les propagandes, quoi. Ça
m'énerve quoi, tu vois.
Propagande de tout bord.
Propagande de tout bord. Tout ce qui est
foireux, tout ce qui est tout ce qu'il
faut dire pour répéter, pour plaire aux
autres. Ça ça m'énerve quoi. Je suis un
peu un emmerdeur.
Alors aujourd'hui, on va parler
journalisme d'investigation, on va
parler journalisme tout courts,
audiovisuel et surtout ce que vous levez
sur votre site internet qui s'appelle
offigation.
Yes.
La première question que je vais vous
poser, c'est pourquoi vous êtes pas venu
plutôt nous voir ?
Alors, on a failli venir vous voir
plutôt parce que il y a 3 ans à peu
près, il s'est passé un truc marrant.
Euh, on a un jeune mec qui nous aidait à
lancer le média indépendant, à lancer
des campagnes de don, qui a une bonne
idée, qui s'est dit "Putain, je vais
appeler Sky à Syerview pour proposer
d'interviewer Rivard." Et je crois, vous
allez me dire si c'est ça, je crois
qu'il a dit euh euh "Si euh si vous
invitez mon pote, je vous envoie le
livre qui vient de sortir."
La phrase exacte c'était "Si vous me
garantissez une interview, je vous
envoie le livre."
Voilà. Si vous me garantissez une
interview, je vous envoie le bouquin.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai répondu ? Ben j'en
sais rien. Moi, j'étais pas dans votre
conversation, mais apparemment ça ça
vous a pas trop plu. Donc euh vous lui
avez dit euh "Oui, je suis libre
éditoalement, je fais ce que je veux, on
me dicte pas." Non, on a pas dit ça.
J'ai dit euh quand vous commencez votre
phrase par si, on raccroche,
d'accord ?
Que ce soyez que ce soit un journaliste,
n'importe qui, il y a aucune condition à
nous imposer et on ne vous a pas parlé
pendant pratiquement 4 ans à cause de
ça.
Exactement. Et heureusement pour vous,
on a un ami que vous connaissez qui m'a
demandé de regarder votre travail en
insistant et j'ai regarder votre travail
et c'était de haute teneur intellectuel
et de très bonne qualité.
Merci.
Et donc on a décidé de reprendre contact
avec vous et là vous m'avez expliqué que
c'était une erreur d'un attaché de
presse et voilà.
C'est pas un attaché de presse, c'est un
mec jeune qui savait pas les codes et
quand il m'a raconté qu'il avait dit à à
Sky si vous l'invitez, je vous envoie le
bouquin. J'étais mort de rire en fait.
Je bah parce que je t'ai m'endormir.
Parce que tu sais très bien que quand
dans le journalisme tu dis pas au mec
euh si tu l'invites je te fais le
bouquin. C'est plutôt je t'envoie le
bouquin et si ça t'intéresse tu peux
l'inviter, tu vois. Donc ça c'était fait
à l'envers. Mais le mec il est gentil en
fait hein. C'est juste ça s'est fait à
l'envers. Évidemment ça vous a braqué et
euh donc après on s'était changé un
petit texto. Je faisais dit non mais
juste le mec il est jeune ne stress
faites ce que vous voulez il y a pas de
problème. Vous pouvez pas nous inviter,
il y a aucun problème. Voilà c'est bon
tout va bien.
On est relativement bourru surtout que
qu'on connaît pas les numéros de
téléphone qui nous appellent. En
général, on a on a tendance à recevoir
sur les roses les gens ou les orties,
les gens qui nous appellent qu'on
connaît pas. Surtout un lundi de pâqu à
5h de l'après-midi.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Yes.
Vous avez bossé un peu chez Canal Plus.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé chez Canal ?
Euh pour faire très court entre 2000 et
pour faire
Sinkerview, on a le temps.
Super. Alors, attends entre moi je
rentre moi je passe 8 10 ans à l'agence
CAPA comme reporter euh grand reporter
et après Canal en 2000 pendant une
quinzaine d'années 2000 2015 Canal en
gros ça va pas mal on fait à peu près ce
qu'on veut. Bon il y a quand même des
petits moments où ça coince un peu mais
très peu. Bon je sais pas on emmerde un
ministre socialiste, il appelle la
direction de la chaîne, ça commence à se
tendre. Euh ça m'avait marqué parce que
ça arrivait pas souvent mais en règle
générale entre deux greffes l'Escure et
les dirigeants de canal de l'époque en
Grè génal il faisaient euh il faisaient
euh armure quoi. Il protégeaient les
guignoles, il protégeaient le
l'investigation et on nous foutait pas
mal la paix. Et franchement euh bon
voilà peut-être parce que j'étais aussi
dans une ligne d'éditoriale qui était
proche de la chaîne à l'époque mais
franchement j'avais l'impression qu'on
faisait à peu près ce qu'on voulait et
qu'on avait un espèce de rôle
d'aiguillon de faire un peu chier le
système audiovisuel et canal. C'est pour
ça que moi j'y étais c'était marrant de
pouvoir aller un peu plus loin que les
autres ou se [__] un peu de la gueule
des gens ou faire un peu ce qu'on
voulait et c'était c'était assez cool en
terme de liberté. Et j'avais le
sentiment moi à l'époque, c'était quand
même à peu près la seule chaîne où on
pouvait faire ça parce que voilà parce
que parce que TF1 M6 c'était quand même
beaucoup plus commercial et parce que
dans l'audiovisuel public c'est quand
même beaucoup plus soumis au pouvoir
politique. Euh je fais cours enfin moi
je vous raconter une anecdote quand
quand je commence tout jeune à 22 ans à
France 3, je commence par faire le tour
des bureaux de France 3 en région comme
contrat 3 jours jeune reporter
caméraman. on me donne un peu de quoi me
loger machin et cetera. Et un jour,
j'arrive je sais pas quoi à France 3
Nancy. Il se passe un truc marrant,
c'est qu'en fait je découvre qu'il y a
une polémique autour de l'installation
d'une usine
EDF ou nucléaire dans le coin. Il y a
une grosse polémique avec des gens qui
font des pétitions contre l'usine et
cetera. Et le patron du bureau local de
France 3, je m'aperçois qu'en fait il
anime un débat payé par EDF pour parler
à la population du projet qui dérange la
population. Mais le mec, il est payé par
ADF, c'est le directeur de France 3 et
personne veut aller filmer ce trucl et
moi je suis con, moi je suis jeune, je
suis là, il me dit "Bah toi, tu vas
venir faire le reportage." Je me dis
"Mais attends, je vais faire un
reportage sur le patron de l'antenne de
France 3 payé par EDF qui fait style
anime un débat qu'il est neutre." Tu
vois, c'est un peu compliqué. Donc ça me
fait marrer, j'y vais.
Boulot de journaliste,
je prends ma caméra, j'arrive, je vois
que le mec il est dans sa dans je sais
pas sur quelle chaise il est, tu vois,
il est journaliste France 3, il est payé
par EDF, il fait quoi ? Bref, je prends
ma caméra puis je me dis bah je peux pas
filmer le mec parce qu'il va avoir l'air
con après dans le reportage. Donc je le
filme pas. Et je reviens à la rédaction
et le lendemain il fait bon ben alors ce
soir dans le journal on a le reportage
qu'a fait le le le le Jean-Baptiste là
qui a tourné hier soir pour pour le
journal de ce soir. Là je fais
excusez-moi
j'ai pas filmé. Du quoi tu as pas filmé
? Bah je disement parce que vous étiez
entre deux vous avez deux bl casquettes.
Là j'étais un peu embêté. C'était un peu
gênant pour vous. J'ai pas filmé. Bon
bon d'accord ok c'est pas grave. [rires]
Je me suis dit c'est un peu bizarre
France 3 région. Alors, c'est pas
toujours comme ça. Franchement, il y a
plein de gens qui bossent bien François,
mais là, je me suis dit "Mais c'est quoi
ce mélange des genres de communication
et du journalisme ?" Bon, ça veut pas
dire que c'est ça France télé, mais bon,
bref. Après je sais par des copains qui
sont à France télé que les pressions
politiques sont quand même importantes
et en fait voilà quoi. Donc Canal
c'était c'était vraiment bien et puis en
2015 arrive alors nous on comprend pas
qu'arrive Vincent Boloré en fait nous
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe. Moi
je suis redac chef adjoint de spéciale
investigation depuis 5 ans une émission
hebdo d'investigation 52 tous les lundis
et qui cartonnait
qui marchait bien qui marchait bien.
L'investigation ça marche plutôt bien à
la télé parce que quand on découvre des
trucs pas connus qu'on gratte un peu et
qu'on emmerde des gens en général le
public il aime bien contrairement à ce
que disent certains. Bref donc ça marche
pas mal. Et en mai 2015, on fait un on a
une des copains qui sont dans une agence
de presse qui nous propose un sujet sur
le Crédit Mutuel qui apparemment
acceptent des valises de cash dans une
filiale à Monaco et par ailleurs
suggèrent à leurs riches clients d'aller
planquer leur fric en Suisse. Donc c'est
intéressant. Ils disent bon on a un
super sujet, ils sont en lien avec Média
Part et tout, c'est des gens qui sont
talentueux. On dit "OK, c'est bon, on y
va, on prend le 52." Depuis de 3 ans à
l'époque, en 2015, la direction de Canal
a instauré un système de comité
d'investigation où on doit quand même
aller demander "Chef, s'il te plaît,
est-ce que je peux faire une enquête dès
qu'on veut lancer un truc Donc on va
quand même leur demander, enfin c'est
pas moi, c'est mon boss he qui va leur
demander chef, on peut dire que la
banque Crédit Mutuel, elle crée un peu
la Ouais ouais bon sujet, vas-y mon
gars, c'est bon. OK. Maxime Saada,
patron de canal encore aujourd'hui.
D'accord, on lance le truc hyper fier et
cetera. Les mecs font l'enquête super
machin, vachement bien et cetera. On est
au printemps 2015 et on p un communiqué
de presse, on va faire trembler le monde
de la banque canal. Nous, on va faire
trembler le monde de la banque. Pit,
c'était drôle. [souffle coupé] Mort de
rire, donc communiqué de presse et tout.
Et le truc est prêt quoi, il est monté
et le on le valide éditoriellement et la
juriste de Canal vient le voir toujours
prudente. Attention les procès machin,
elle règle le truc au millimètre, on
fait gaffe et tout. Nickel, c'est bon,
c'est bon, c'est parti, c'est bon.
Diffusion en 3 semaines, on est en mai
2015. Et après mon boss, il me dit euh
c'est bizarre là, j'ai vu passer un
mail, on est même pas destinataire du
mail, mais il y a marqué au fait on
déprogramme là, faut mettre autre chose.
C'est qui qui a écrit le mail ? un cadre
de canal, envoyer un mail à un autre
cadre de canal pour dire ça va pas en
déprogramme sans même prévenir mon pote
qui était le patron de l'émission quoi.
Et euh là on se dit c'est quoi ce bordel
? Et moi je crois que c'était une blague
et en fait au fil des jours, non c'est
pas une blague. Et donc Stéphan cherche
en urgence un autre truc à mettre parce
qu'il dit là il y a un problème, ils
veulent déprogrammer, je sais pas ce qui
se passe. Donc ni le patron de la chaîne
Rodolphe Belmer ne nous parle ni encore
moins le type qui est à l'origine de
cette censure Vincent Bolloré ne nous
parle. Donc nous on sait pas ce qui se
passe en fait.
Non mais vous vous êtes sûr que c'était
Vincent Mollor himself ?
Alors non à l'époque on sait pas. à
l'époque, on sait le truc est
déprogrammé. OK, d'accord. Donc euh
voilà, c'est chaud quoi. Et euh alors
Stéphaner en urgence un truc à mettre à
la place, mais moi ça m'énerve parce
qu'on passe pour des cons vis-à-vis des
gens qui ont fait le sujet. Enfin, c'est
quoi ce bordel ? Pourquoi c'est
déprogrammé ? Il y a un problème, ça
passe au-dessus de notre tête quoi.
Au-dessus de la tête de la juriste,
audessus de la tête de tout le monde.
Bon, donc il y a un problème. Euh, on
cherche à comprendre, on sait pas qui
Rodolp Vmer, ça dure 3 semaines et
cetera. Et au bout d'un moment, euh, on
croit comprendre par nos copains qu'on
fait le sujet que au sein de la banque,
il y a eu des rumeurs que ça allait être
déprogrammé par Canal et cetera. Bref,
on finit par comprendre par un papier de
Fabrice Arfil Media part en juillet que
il y a eu en fait un coup de fil de
Boloré à Canal. Pourquoi ? Parce que
Boloré, il est pote avec le patron du
Crédit Mutuel, Michel Lucas qui est un
patron breton qui fait partie d'un
cercle le patron breton dont fait partie
Vincent Bolloré que c'est son pote
qu'au-delà de ça, le Crédit Mutuel a
financé la montée de de Boloré dans
Vivindi. Enfin bref, il y a des liens
d'affaires entre eux.
Tout est sourcé ça.
Ah bah oui, ça c'est connu. Oui, crédit
mutuel. Crédit mutuel Vivindice, ça
c'est c'est sourcé. Et et ce que ce que
Harfi révèle le 31 juillet 2015, c'est
qu'il y a eu un coup de fil de Boloré à
Rodolphe Belmaire. Euh euh donc le c'est
révélé en juillet, mais en fait
l'affaire se passe en mai. Ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'à l'époque Rodolphe
Belmer est le patron de Canal. Boloré
est planqué dans les fougières, il est
pas encore sorti mais il appelle
Belmeraire en disant il y a un problème
sur ce sujet genre voilà ça dérange la
banque rituelle, c'est mon pote, je sais
pas quoi, il faut absolument l'enlever.
Donc Belle-Mire va essayer de résister
mais je crois que Boloré lui dit un truc
du genre il faut savoir envoyer
l'ascenseur, il nous a aidé, tu
comprends ? C'est comme ça et cetera. et
Charles Dominique c'est pas je crois que
machin il y a eu cet échange
le coup de fil le coup defil de Bolloré
à Bemmer a été rendu public par Media
Part il y a pas eu de démentie il s'est
rien passé on en a parlé 15 fois depuis
donc oui il y a eu un coup de fil de de
Vincent Boloré Ardolf Bmer Boloré après
s'en expliquer en disant non mais moi
j'ai attiré son attention sûre et cetera
mais bon voilà il fait ce qu'il veut de
toute façon après Bolorie toujours moi
je suis pas le patron j'ai pas le
pouvoir c'est lui qui a décidé c'est
vrai queofficiellement c'est le patron
de Canal Plus Rodolphe Belmer qui à ce
moment-là dit enfin n'arrive pas à
résister en fait à la pression du nouvel
actionnaire Boloré juste depuis quelques
mois est devenu le premier actionnaire
de Vivindi.
C'est c'est une mensuétude de cours.
C'est quoi ?
Euh de la part de Rodolphe. [grognement]
Euh juste nous à l'époque on a même pas
compris que Boloré est en train
d'arriver. Ça fait 4 ans qu'il grimpe au
capital de Vivindi Discr en en
concertation avec Sarkozy depuis 2011
parce que enfin je t'expliquerai à
l'occasion mais c'est hyper intéressant
en fait. Il y a un problème entre Sarco
et Canal absolument majeur pendant 15
ans. Sarkozi va jamais réussir à faire
terre les emmerdeurs de Canal ni les
Guignol ni les autres ni Bruno Gou.
alors qu'il est foudrage contre lui. Il
devient président en 2007, il se dit
"Putain là je suis président, ça va
chier." Il met des pressions dans tous
les sens, il engueule tous les
dirigeants de canal, les vivind machin,
il obtient pas ce qu'il veut alors qu'il
Ouais, il plein de papiers dans le
canard, il gueule plusieurs fois, "J'en
ai marre du canal, c'est pas possible.
Quand c'est pas le grand journal, c'est
le zapping. Quand c'est pas le zapping,
c'est qui guignolle." Sarco, il est fou,
furieux contre Canal entre 2007 et 2012.
Il met des coups de pression monstrueux
sur l'actionnariat de la chaîne 15 fois.
OK. il se heurte au fait que euh bah en
fait voilà euh ça résiste quoi. C'est
plus l'époque le greffe l'escur la
grande époque mais n'empêche que mais
eux et les autres ils sont un peu
traumatisés par le fait que Gasou et ses
potes ils ont fait des révoltes en 2002.
Ils ont peur que si on étouffe les
guignoles ça va le le chaudron va va
péter. Donc ils osent pas, ils savent
pas comment faire. Ils arrivent pas à
contrôler. Et ce qui est marrant c'est
qu'à la fin du quinquena Sarkozi, on est
à peu près en 2011, Sarco veut se
représenter à la présidentielle. Sauf
qu'il se dit il y a un problème parmi
d'autres dans mon parcours de
réélection, ça s'appelle Canal Plus et
les guignol de l'info et le zapping et
cetera. Il paraît qu'un jour il a dit la
direction de Canal le vrai problème
c'est le zap pareil.
Alors la source
euh quelqu'un très important au zapping
m'a révélé qu'une fois parce qu'il le
savait de la direction de la chaîne que
un jour Sarkozy a fait savoir que
c'était plus le zapping qui lui posait
le problème que les guignoles. Ça peut
paraître étonnant parce que les
guignoles étaient assez cruels avec
Sarco mais en fait le zapping était un
problème. Pourquoi ? Parce que le boulot
de Patrick Maiet et de ses équipes, ça
reprenait toutes les petites perles de
la télé. Des fois, il y avait des
énormités. Je vous donne un exemple. Un
jour, Sarco va le salon de
l'agriculture, un mec l'engueule, il dit
"Casse-toi, pauvre con". Bon ça une fois
à la té ça fait mal. Repris dans le
zapping toute la soirée, ça fait encore
plus mal. Et dans l'année du zapping,
tout le monde est mort de rire. Et ça
c'était un vrai problème pour Sarkozi
d'après ce qu'on a compris. Voilà. Bon
ça après c'est donc bref, tout ça pour
dire que Sarko est fou furieux contre
Canal. En 2011, euh Jean-René Fourtou,
patron du groupe Vivindi, euh un ancien
chirraakien qui essaie de se remettre du
côté de Sarco lui dit "Écoutez Nicolas,
quand même votre quinquena était
formidable. On aimerait bien que vous
soyez réélu." Et là, Sarco et ses
conseillers lui disent "Mais c'est
lunaire en fait, vous êtes le patron de
Vivand Canal qui me chie dessus toute la
journée. Vous voulez qu'on soit réélu ?
Alors là, je comprends pas bien, il va
falloir tenir vos guignoles quoi. Bon et
Fourtou, je sais pas pourquoi, avait du
mal à tenir la chaîne, à tenir ses
trublions. Voilà, parce il y avait une
culture qui lui faisait peur et cetera.
En bref, et il va organiser secrètement
ce qu'on a appelé le groupe pourtou en
2011. Il va réunir des gens importants,
des médias ou ou de de pouvoir,
quinzaine de types qui se réunissent
régulièrement pour travailler à la
réélection de Sarco, favoriser la
révision de SarkoZi groupe pour tout. Tu
as dedans des gens de TF1, tu as dedans
Jean-Christophe Thierry, actuellement un
des de lieutenants de Vincent Boloré.
C'est c'est sourcé tout ça.
C'est documenté. Moi je l'ai raconé dans
le bouquin, c'est archi documenté. Gr
pour tout se réunit de manière
confidentielle. pas à l'Élysée parce que
c'est gênant, plutôt chez Fourtou et
cetera. Euh est présent un conseiller de
Sarkozy qui s'appelle Camille Pascal,
est présent aussi Jean-Christophe
Thierry du groupe Boloré. un certain
nombre de gens sont là et et là Sarco
commence à se dire bon bah si vraiment
Fourtou bou bouge son cul pour que je
sois réu peut-être que bon mais mais il
y a toujours les emmerneur de canal au
milieu. Et à ce moment-là je pense que
Fourtou n'arrive pas à calmer sa propre
chaîne en fait et il va commencer à
parler avec Vincent Bolloray qui a la
réputation déjà à l'époque de tenir ses
médias d'une main de fer et il va le
pousser à entrer au capital de Vivindi
de mon interprétation. Alors là c'est
subjectif parce que Sarco est fouf
contre Canal Fourtout n'y arrive pas. On
est à un an d'une élection
présidentielle et faut tout trouver une
espèce de solution de sortie. Je vais
faire rentrer Bolloret, lui il aura de
la poignée.
J'aim pas les choses subjectives.
Je peux pas aller au-delà. Je suis pas
dans le secret de leur conversation mais
il y a un moment donné des faits puis
après tu fais une interprétation. Là je
suis sur Oui. Ben d'accord mais alors
attends. Alors OK, on va rester sur ce
qui est factuel. C'est ça que tu veux ?
Je sais pas. On va rester Je ne veux que
du factuel d'une triangulation
irréprochable.
OK. Alors
charte de Munique ça te parle ?
On reprend.
C'est quoi la charte de Munique ? Oui,
la charte Dominique, c'est la charte
d'éthique des journalistes. On essaie de
la respecter tous les jours. Après euh
comment te dire euh non mais on peut moi
si vous souhaitez, on reste strictement
sur des faits établis. Après, il y a des
moments où à partir des faits, on
réfléchit, on propose des
interprétations. L'honnêteté, c'est
retoir.
Voilà, l'honnêteté c'est mais un peu
fait à l'instant, c'est je pense qu'on
peut interpréter ça comme ça, mais
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait l'interpréter
autrement et j'ai pas de certitude.
Voilà. Mais ce ce que ce que ce que je
sais c'est que en 2011 donc ce qui est
factuel Fourtou va faire rentrer Boloré
dans le capital de Vivadi. En gros tu
nous files tes deux chaînes gratuites là
qui peuvent nous arranger et nous on te
file une partie du capital de Vivandi.
Donc Boloré va échanger D8 et D17 contre
je sais plus combien 2,5 % du capital de
Vivindi. D'ailleurs, les chaînes vont
être valorisées bien au-dessus de leur
valeur d'après ce qui ressort à
l'époque. C'estàd que Vivindi fait un
vrai cadeau à Bolloré parce que les
chaînes marchaient pas. Il y avait pas
grand monde qui regardait. Bon, il lui
donne une partie du capital de VV qui
est très élevé trois fois la valeur des
chaînes. Bon et surtout à l'époque les
gens disent "Ah bah Boloré vend ses
chaînes, il sort des médias." La
majorité de la presse se vautre dans
l'interprétation. Elles pensent que
Boloré sort des médias. À l'époque notre
confrère Markevel qui est assez fin dans
ces observations,
on l'embrasse, [rires]
on l'embrasse comprend qu'en fait non,
Boloré est en train d'entrer dans le
capitale de Vivindi qui est la maison
maire de Canal qui est en train de
prendre une position importante qui ne
sort pas du tout des médias. D'ailleurs,
il va dire Boloré dans deux trois
journaux, il parle pas beaucoup, je me
mets dans la boquette arrière de Canal,
c'est un peu les meilleurs, je regarde
comment ils font. So entendu de dans 2
ans, je saute sur ma proie et je prends
le volant quoi. Donc Markel comprend ça,
il parle à quelques journaux tiens,
c'est ça qui se passe et tout. Personne
le croit, personne prend ses papiers. Il
avait pourtant raison. Je fais cours
hein. Voilà. Donc tout ça pour dire que
Boloré rentre, les gens comprennent pas
vraiment ce qui se passe. Et alors
d'après une un aveu de de donc de d'un
des conseillers de SarkoZi
Camille Pascal euh Boloré fait
comprendre à Sarkozy ou à Camille
Pascal, je vais rentrer au capital de
Vadi pour prendre monter en puissance et
prendre le pouvoir au sein de Canal et
en gros virer les gauchistes et les mecs
qui qui emmerdent Sarkozi quoi. il va
informer
ceux qui tapaient trop de coques au
festival de Can
entre autres. Alors il y en avait qui
prenaient de la coque, il y en avait
aussi qui faisaient chez les politiques,
il y avait de tout à Canal [rires]
donc et donc et donc Boloré dès le
septembre 2011 mais personne ne l'a
compris à l'époque rentre au capital de
dit discrètement avec une avec à mon
avis un projet politique extrêmement
clair de enfin éradiquer cette chaîne
qui emmerdait son pote Sarkozi depuis 15
ans sans que Sarkozi lui-même n'ait
réussi à l'étrangler.
C'est sûr que c'est son pote
Boloré Sarkozi. Alors il lui a prêté son
yachot en 2007 et son jet. Oui, ils ont
toujours été assez proches et tout
permet de penser qu'en 20112 2012 et
cetera, il y a une proximité réelle
entre les deux, une proximité politique.
Ça a changé non ?
Ah, ça peut-être changé après. Là, je
suis en 2011 et donc et donc Boloré va
monter au capital, il va pas réussir à
étrangler Canal en 6 mois parce que
Vivindi avant d'arriver à 15 % du
capital, c'est des milliards d'euros, il
va mettre 4 ans mais il va commencer à
grignoter et il arrive pas à être anglis
Canal pour l'élection de 2012. Donc
c'est Hollande qui passe. [grognement]
Et alors ce qui est fou c'est que pas
forcément connu, c'est qu'entre 2012 et
2015, son arrivée effective à la tête de
cette boîte, il va avoir des des
problèmes dans sa montée au capital de
Vivindi parce que la caisse des dépôts
veut se retirer, parce que à un moment
donné Fourtou change d'avis, veut mettre
un allemand, bref, il a des problèmes. À
chaque fois Bolloré va à l'Élysée, il va
rencontrer Macron et Hollande et surtout
le conseiller breton de François
Hollande qui s'appelle je sais plus
comment l'ancien maire de Quimpère.
Bref, enfin, je vais le retrouver. Donc
euh Boloré a un contact très étroit avec
Hollande via le conseiller euh Bernard
Poignan de François Hollande qui a son
petit bureau en haut de l'Élysée. Et
donc Boloré que dès qu'il y a un
problème, il va voir l'Élysée de
Hollande, il dit "Aidez-moi" et cetera.
et les mecs vont l'aider en fait à
débarrasser les obstacles pour qu'il
monte effectivement au capitale de Vadi.
Donc en fait c'est la Hollandie qui a
permis à Boloré de monter au capital de
Vadi et d'arriver en 2014 à prendre la
tête du conseil de surveillance et en
2015 février 2015 c'est génial il a en
réalité le pouvoir. Nous on l'a pas du
tout compris il va France interre et là
tuas salam qui lui ditesprit canal ça
vous branche ça vous fait marrer tout ça
? Oui, j'aime bien. Mais quand il se
moque des autres, c'est moins bien.
Quand il se moque de même, c'est bien,
mais quand il se moque des autres, c'est
moins bien. Voilà, il dit ce truc là. Et
donc nous en février 2015, quand il dit
ça sur France Ter, on capte pas. Mais
les guignoles, ils ont entendu Boloré
qui dit "Quand l'esprit canal se moque
des autres, c'est pas bien. Quand ils se
moquent d'eux, c'est bien. En fait, tu
vois bon, les guignoles qui comprennent
tout de suite. Moi, j'ai pas capté
l'époque hein. Ils font un sketch le
soir même, on est en plateau, tu as
Boloré qui explique qu'est-ce qui est
drôle et tuas PPDA qui rampe et qui
rigole. Bah oui, je rigole pas trop
parce que vous avez dit que c'est drôle.
Donc il se foutent de la gueule de
Boloré qui dicteraiit-ce que c'est
l'humour. Boloré est furieux, personne
le sait, personne le voit. Un mois plus
tard, il faut un sketch.
Comment tu sais queil est furieux ?
Bah parce que un mois plus tard, ils
vont faire un sketch mettant en scène
enfin se foutant à nouveau de la gueule
de Bolloré. Lui, il bouge pas. On est en
mars 2015. OK. En mai, on apprend que
nous le sujet sur le crédit Mel dérange
son pote, c'est au revoir, nous on est
vert quoi. Et fin juin, il commence à
dire "Alors les guignoles, c'est stop."
Et Rodolphe Belmer, patron de Canal a
cédé pour nous en mai 2015 sur le Crédit
Mutuel. Il a cédé, il nous l'a pas dit.
Il ne l'a voilà, il n'a pas dit.
On s'est retrouvé avec un sujet par
terre, on savait pas à cause du qui
c'était. Je pense qu'il c'était
compliqué pour lui d'assumer ça. Nous à
sa pas, on sait pas. Et en juin, Boloré
monte d' cran, c'est non seulement le
crédit mutuel, mais maintenant vous
allez shooter les guignoles de l'info.
Et là, Belle-Mère
lui dit "Bah non, en fait, enfin c'est
compliqué quoi." Donc il prévient les
les équipes. Les équipes des guignoles
font fuiter dans la presse que Boloré
veut supprimer les guignoles. Bolloré
dit pas du tout "Qu'est-ce c'est que
histoire ?" Boloré s'aperçoit qu'en fait
les mecs sont en train de lui faire un
chantier en balançant tout dans la
presse. Ça fait la une de Libé tous les
jours d' on parle. Boloré est furieux.
Euh et en gros, d'après ce qu'on nous a
expliqué, belle-memère va le voir en
disant "Si vous supprimez les guignoles
de l'info, je me barre de la chaîne, je
je quitte la direction de cette chaîne"
et Boré lui aurait répondu "On va garder
les guignoles de l'info et toi tu
dégages. On est début juillet 2015."
Donc il y a une violence terrible. En
fait, Bolor commence à faire un ménage
radical comme il fait toujours. Donc il
va virer la direction de cette chaîne.
Il va euh finalement inextrémiste le 3
juillet quand toute la presse dit "C'est
horrible, tu peux faire du diable ?"
Ouais. ce que je fais à chaque fois
bien sûr
canel un peu c'était un peu la gabie non
la couque les grandes les grandes
chambres can et vasic machin
ouais ça c'est son grand argument tu
vois il dit toujours oui ça me fait
marrer il a dit 15 fois ce truc là oui
canal les mecs ils avaient du fric et
moi il m'envolent parce que je suis
arrivé j'ai un peu resserré les finances
ah vas-y c'est bon quoi.
Le groupe le groupe était dans quel état
financier à l'époque ? Bon, je je sais
pas, le groupe était moyen, le groupe
était pas euh enfin, il y avait pas ça
cartonnait pas autant que 10 ans avant,
c'était un peu préoccupant, fallait
réfléchir et cetera, mais euh enfin, je
veux dire, c'était quand même un modèle
économique surabonnement avec des
millions d'abonnés avec pas énormément
de salariés qui étaient gérable. C'était
pas c'était pas une panique, c'était pas
ça le problème quand Boloré, c'est pas
France Télévision,
c'est un autre sujet, on va parler
après. Non mais quand quand Boris dit
Canal claquait trop d'argent et bon
après il y avait peut-être des bols de
coque et franchement moi quand je suis
arrivé 15 ans avant un Canal, j'avais un
peu l'impression que des fois on jetait
des billets de 500 balles par la
fenêtre. Enfin pas moi hein, mais en
terme de prod, c'était un peu large,
c'était un peu cool l'organisation de
Canal. C'est vrai, mais c'est pas le
problème majeur parce que tu peux dire
"Ouais, l'hôtel à Cann enfin moi quand
j'étais à Cann pour le festival de Can
pour Canal, j'avais un scooter, je
dormais dans une dans un tu sais comment
s'appelle les trucs enf je sais pas les
une roulotte.
Non pas une roulotte, c'était le Pierre
et vacances. Pierre et vacances.
Pierre et vacances.
Voilà, c'est bien. Non, mais tu vois,
j'étais pas au Hilton quoi contrairement
à ce que dit Boloré. Donc bon, c'est un
faux débat. Boloré, il dit ça pour dire
en fait il a fait une reprise en main
politique et intellectuelle de cette
chaîne radicale notamment pour protéger
Sarco mais aussi pour ce qu'on
découvrira plus tard un projet civil
civilisationnel beaucoup plus à droite
que ce que Canal mais comme c'est pas ça
qu'il voulait dire il a dit non mais
c'est pour raison d'argent. Bon c'est un
peu c'est un peu bidon. Bref, donc euh
donc après là voilà, on a arrivé à l'été
2015 avec une reprise en main absolument
terrible de la chaîne et notamment euh
un épisode qu'on va raconter dans un
futur documentaire qu'on aimerait bien
produire si notre campagne de don actuel
fonctionne parce qu'on va lancer cinq
documentaires sur les les pressions sur
l'humour politique en France et un de
ces doc, on veut faire absolument
l'histoire secrète de l'émission Guignol
de l'info, histoire politique.
La plateforme, c'est quelle plateforme ?
Euh on lance une campagne de don euh via
notre site. Euh en fait euh tu vas sur
off investigation euh faites un don
machin, tu fais un don des fiscalisable
quoi. Euh donc on a on est on est en
permanence en train de se financer par
des dons citoyens parce que c'est notre
seul mode de financement.
C'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait aussi. Le
seul mode de financement de Seriew,
c'est que par les dons sur Tipi. Donc si
vous voulez qu'on continue et qu'on
puisse être indépendant et qu'on puisse
continuer à recevoir des emmerdeurs,
voilà,
il faut nous soutenir sur Tipi. On a
besoin de vous parce que sinon on va
calencher et on va tomber et vous allez
vous retrouver tout seul que avec et
ce sera le sujet d'une émission
d'ailleurs.
C'est bien,
on dépend tous des citoyens mais comme
il y en a 70 millions, je pense qu'on va
y arriver comme
parce que nous, contrairement à toi, on
touche aucune subvention. On a pas de
niche fiscale et on a pas de carte de
presse.
OK. Alors, vous avez pas de déficit. OK.
Non, juste alors nous sur les
subventions, juste d'un mot en fait, on
a décidé il y a un ou 2 mois qu'on
arrête de demander euh toute subvention
publique. Donc euh on demande plus le
CNC pour plein de raisons que je
pourrais expliquer, voilà. Et onira plus
chercher ce qu'on appelle les aides au
pluralisme qui a les médias, normalement
tous les médias. Pourquoi ? pour faire
extrêmement court parce qu'en fait
l'État prend dans la prend dans les
impôts des millions et des millions et
des millions d'euros qui vont à 80 90 %
à 5 milliardaires potes de Macron qui
tiennent les médias pour que servir
leurs intérêts industriels et il y a
quelques miettes pour les médias indés
mais vraiment quelques miettes faut leur
faire une demande en trois exemplaires
quatre fois faut leur faire un rapport
financier ils te saoulent et nous en
plus ils nous disent les de tiers de
votre masse salariale on la prend pas en
compte parce que c'est des réatrices de
documentaires. Je leur dis je vois pas
le rapport mais c'est comme ça. Donc en
fait ça saoule ce système des aides à la
presse il est super injuste. Il pèse sur
les gens et il finance. Le principal
financé par ces aides à la presse, il
s'appelle Bernard Arnaud LVMH. Donc
autant dire que nous les aides à la
presse, c'est pas trop notre c quoi. Et
donc on a décidé pour raison
d'indépendance vis-à-vis de l'État
aussi. On a pas envie d'aller demander
du fric ni à Macron, ni demain à Jordan
ou à Jean-Luc quoi. Donc on a décidé
qu'on donne plus d'argent à l'État et on
a décidé de parler aux citoyens
franchement dans les yeux en disant bah
soit vous financez la presse
indépendante, soit on va pas y arriver
et comme ça on se débarrasse de tout un
tas de problèmes, c'est plus simple
quoi.
Bienvenue au club,
continue ton histoire.
Non mais en en deux mots donc je sais
plus où j'en étais du coup
canal reprendre Boloré. Ouais. Donc en
fait si tu veux ce qui se passe donc
Boloré vir Bellemè il a arrêté le Crédit
Mutuel, c'est un message pour nous genre
l'investigation fait pas chier et après
les guignoles c'est alors il arrive pas
à les tuer parce qu'il y a une campagne
de presse et làdessus il va sur Europain
il fait moi ah mais pas du tout je les
adore. Ah la guignole un actif important
pour Canal Plus enfin Boloré enfin un de
ses meilleurs potes disait un jour sur
France 2 il est charmant mais mais il
est si menteur
Bori. Il m dans les yeux dans les yeux
toute la journée he c'est formidable.
Les guignoles, j'adore. Il nous sort ça
en juillet 2015. Sauf que
ils m'ont pas tout le temps.
Non, ils m'ont pas tout le temps. Ils
m'ont souvent. Ils m'ont souvent. Mais
pour dire queil y a un truc ton
interprétation.
Non mais je je ça fait un moment que je
travaille parce que j'ai fait un bouquin
de travailler 4 ans. Il m'a mis dans un
placard 4 ans. J'ai pu faire un livre
donc j'ai travaillé un peu sur mis dans
un placard. [rires]
Je vais te raconter après parce que mais
on y arrive. Donc juste sur les juillet
2015 il dit non mais je veux pas du tout
tuer les guignoles, ils sont super. On
va juste changer un peu. Donc on va
arrêter de parler des politiques, on va
faire Kim Kardachian et je sais pas
quoi. Et on va plus être en direct.
Alors ça quand tu fais un peu de télé,
tu sais très bien que plus de direct
déjà ça craint. Et alors les politiques
c'est pas intéressant. Tu fais OK, c'est
terminé et là il se passe un truc super
marrant qu'on racontera dans quelques
mois dans un épisode sur l'histoire
secrète des guignoles de l'info. C'est
que l'équipe des guignoles face à ça va
avoir une quasi implosion, va avoir un
problème, va va comprendre qu'il y a un
enjeu terrible et un des mecs de
l'équipe va dire bah il veut faire ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Boloré il attend
une soumission de l'équipe des Guignoles
à ce moment-là. Il dit "Bon, je vous ai
préservé mais alors par contre il y a
plus une tête qui sort." Et là, il y a
un des mecs qui dit "Bah, on a qu'à dire
que oui oui oui chef, on va faire ça.
Puis on revient en septembre à la
rentrée, puis on pète tout, on parle de
Bolloré, ce qu'il a fait sur la chaîne
et cetera." Et là, un autre responsable
de l'émission lui dit "Hors de question,
tu es fou, on va saboter le programme,
il y a 200 emplois à la clé." Pas du
tout. Euh, on va on va on va courber les
Chines. En gros, on fait un peu ça
l'idée, hein, quand même, hein. Et euh
et le mec qui avait dit euh, "Ça serait
bien qu'on dise à Boloré, ouais, ouais,
tu as raison." Puis en septembre, tu
vois, 1 heure après, il a un coup de fil
direction de la chaîne qui lui dit "Toi,
terminé
sourcil ça."
Toi, terminé bien sûr sourcil, toi
terminé et et tes potes aussi d'ailleurs
terminé tout le monde terminé. Les
auteurs en juillet 2015 dégagent parce
que Canaal a compris qu'ils étaient en
train de préparer un bout. Ils sont tous
fumés dans les 3 semaines. Et quand ils
sont convoqués au siège de Vivadi à venu
de Friedland, euh, on imagine les mecs
un peu énervés, tu vois. On tue, on est
en train de tuer en fait les Guinof de
l'info. Faut être clair. Dès l'été 2015,
alors qu'ils mourront vraiment en 2018,
quand ils sont convoqués à Vivindi, un
de nous raconte que il est reçu par un
par un sbir de de Boloré qui lui dit
"Bon,
tu es quand même super talentueux, on va
pas se disputer. D'ailleurs, tu es un
peu scénariste toi, tu es tu es auteur,
tu vas faire des scénarios de film et on
va se revoir. On va se revoir." Tu vois,
un petit chèque enfin tu vois tu [rires]
Et même pire que ça le mec lui fait le
mec qui reçoit l'auteur des guignoles,
le bras droit de Boloré appelle ses
potes. Oh c'est le mec qui a fait un
super sketch. Ah venez voir les gars,
c'est le super mec et cetera. Donc ils
le reçoivent pour le lourder. Ils disent
"Tu es génial ! E ton prochain scène
autre film tu auras un chèque ils ont
fait ça avec tous les gens. Et quelque
part, bah en fait, tu te fais fumer ta
carrière d'auteur des guignoles, tu dis
"Bah ouais, demain, je vais essayer de
faire des films et cetera comme a fait
Jean-François Alain par exemple au SS
117ur des guignoles. Bon, tu évidemment
tu vas dans le cinéma, tu vas dans le
cinéma, tu vas dire alors je vais aller
voir qui pour avoir du financement, ben
un peu Canal Plus." Et les mecs sont
tellement sûr d'eux, ils savent très
bien que tu vas revenir faire toc toc
dans 3 mois. Donc ça s'est passé
tranquillement.
Bon bref, ça c'est été 2015. Voilà. Et
après bon ben voilà, moi je suis déprimé
cet été-là parce que j'ai compris qu'en
fait l'investigation ça devenir
compliqué avec Boloré et euh et voilà en
octobre 2015 j'ai un copain syndicaliste
qui me dit bah on va te faire un mandat
syndical pour te protéger. Alors moi à
l'époque je sais pas ce que c'est. Je
dis c'est quoi un mandat syndical ? Bah
c'est le truc qui fait que tu pourras
pas te faire virer en 5 minutes si par
hasard on veut te virer parce que là à
mon avis ils vont te mettre une balle
dans la tête quoi.
Au sens figuré.
Oui figuré figuré figuré. Non mais parce
que voilà parce que parce que moi j'ai
un peu gueulé sur la censure du Crédit
Mutuel mais sans le sortir à l'extérieur
mais en interne on a dit à la direction
attendez on passe pour des cons. Tout
l'été il y a des abonnés de Canal qui
nous disent bah c'est quoi ce bordel ?
Alors vous faites censurer quand c'est
vous foutez en grève du coup on peut
plus croire ce que vous dites parce
qu'il y a des sujets que vous pouvez
plus traiter. Enfin c'est fini tu vois
la crédibilité pour l'investigation.
Voilà et donc octobre 2015 mon mon mon
copain me dit "Vas-y, on va te faire un
syndical parce que là ça va chauffer et
cetera." Je fais "Ah bon d'accord." Et
un matin à 8h, je fais un petit mail à
mon boss en disant bah écoute, je prends
un mandat syndical pour pouvoir essayer
de défendre un peu l'investigation tous
les mois au comité d'entreprise auprès
de la direction. Et là à 11h, j'ai un
copain qui m'appelle qui me dit "Mais tu
as fait quoi ce matin ?" Bah je sais
pas. Bah non parce que là ils sont en
train de préparer une lettre de
licenciement tu vois. Alors je dis bah
ah bon mais je viens de prendre un enfin
leur annoncer que je prends un mandat
syndical. Donc normalement c'est pas
possible. En fait les copains de la CGT
ils avaient pas eu le temps d'envoyer le
mandat. Donc la direction de la chaîne
elle se dit elle a demandé à la DRH il
est arrivé son mandat syndical là ? Non,
il est pas arrivé. Paf, on [rires] va le
fumer. Et la Drache leur dit "Mais vous
êtes fous en fait, il a annoncé le
mandat syndical, on peut pas, c'est
illégal de le virer. Vas-y, on y va
quand même." Machin, l'aide de
licenciement. Et après, les mecs de
Bolloré, ils ont tourné autour de mes
potes du syndicat. "Faut qu'on s'arrange
avec ce garçon." Moi ça m'énerve parce
que si tu me dis que tu vas me virer et
qu'après on va s'arranger, ça m'énerve.
Je dis "Moi, tu m'as convoqué, tu m'as
convoqué, j'attends le recommander, je
viens, tu vois." Bon bref. Et donc ça se
termine.
Mon propre chef m'appelle en me disant
"Mais ça fait 3 jours que tu réponds
pas, on comprend pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?" Je dis "Mais moi, ils m'ont
convoquer lundi prochain, donc moi je
vais à la convocation, tu vois." Non
mais parce qu'ils veulent te faire un
chèque.
La direction veut te faire un chèff.
Faut que tu comprennes Jean-Baptiste, on
va te faire un chèque, fais pas des
histoires, un chèque.
Je dis "Moi je m'en fous d'un chèque là,
je comprends pas en fait. Moi je gueule
contre la censure. Ils m'ont convoqué,
je vais aller les voir.
Je suis le con. Non mais
un gros chèque fait un gros chèque
un gros chèque un petit chèque je m'en
fous
c'est quoi un gros chèque
j'en sais rien moi tu sais à l'époque je
suis un peu naïf
bah de toute façon dans le journalisme
c'est commencé tu as enfin tu sais pas
mais enfin tu as un un une année
d'ancienneté tu as droit à un mois de
salaire parce que c'est un métier un peu
précaire donc en règle générale on
considère que si tu te fais virer par un
acte génère au bout de 10 ansa il te
doit 10 mois de salaire donc moi j'avais
20 ans de boîte 20 mois de salaire tu
calcules je on part sur mettons Euh
combien tu gagnais à l'époque ?
À l'époque en 2015 à Canal, moi je suis
payé 5000 balles par mois.
Net euh euros 2015
5000 € 5000 € ouais 5000 € par mois.
[grognement]
Euh et c'est quoi 175000 balles ? 2000
un peu moins de 200000 balles
de quoi ? De sortir avec 20 20 mois de
salaire. Ouais c'est ça ça fait ça fait
150000 €. Donc il me dit non mais ils
vont te faire un gros chèque pour que tu
sortes en fermant ta gueule. En gros,
c'est ça parce que euh faut comprendre
que les les mois de salaire auxquels tu
as droit par les années d'ancienneté,
bah c'est un droit, c'est c'est la base
quoi. Mais en fait ce qu'ils font dans
ce genre, je découvrais hein, dans ce
genre de boîte pour que tout le monde
ferme sa gueule et te dise "Non, mais on
va t'en donner un peu plus mais par
contre tu te tais." Et moi, j'aime pas
ce genre de truc sur ça complètement
pourri. Donc je dis "Bah écoute, chèque
au gros chèque, au petit chèque, je m'en
fous", machin et cetera. Et donc le la
veille du lundi suivant convoqué pour le
licenciement euh il se trouve que je
sais pas, je sais pas comment un
journaliste du monde apprend qu'il y a
cette convocation et il pète un papier
et lendemain matin je suis dans le
bureau de la DRH qui me dit "Mais vous
êtes fou, faut pas en parler, on va
arrêter votre licenciement, on a pas le
droit de vous licencier, taisez-vous
machin." Et au moment où elle me parle
sur son ordateur, elle dépêche à FP la
direction de Canal veut virer un
rédacteur en chef qui a protesté contre
l'ensu fait non non non, on arrête tout,
on vous vire pas. Non mais c'est
terminé, on arrête tout quoi. Son en
panique. Bon voilà, ça commence comme
ça. Ça c'est 2015, ça va durer 5 ans
derrière parce que pendant 5 ans, c'est
un bras de fer. Gardez le silence et
vous sortez avec de l'argent ou alors
vous sortez pas quoi.
Et donc tu es pas sorti.
Ben non parce que moi je leur dis c'est
quoi garder le silence en fait ? Vous
êtes en train de rentrer dans un média
français important. Vous êtes en train
de faire des trucs dont on est témoins
tous les jours qui sont pas
intéressants. Moi je trouve ça hyper
intéressant en tant que journaliste en
fait ce que vous faites quoi. Ils me
disent bah oui mais bon euh faut pas
spécialement parler à l'extérieur hein.
Je dis bah je sais pas dans ce cas-là
laissez-moi travailler. Moi je suis là
je suis rateur chef adjoint de
l'investigation. Donc si on peut pas
travailler bah là je m'ennuie je regarde
ce que vous faites quoi. Puis puis après
bah je vais le raconter parce que c'est
moi c'est mon boulot en fait. Je je sais
pas ou alors je change de métier tu
vois. Et donc me dit non mais ça c'est
pas possible il faut un accord de
silence. Donc à partir de là, ça
commençait mal. On s'est braqué quoi.
Braqué, ça duré 5 ans.
Donc après, j'ai passé le permis VTC
quoi. Tu
Enfin euh tu veux continuer ou pas ?
Non. Euh [rires]
sorti de ton placard, il y a eu combien
de balai dedans ?
Euh combien de balais il y avait dans le
placard ?
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Combien de combien de mecs étaient avec
toi dans le placard ? Tu étais tout seul
?
Alors, j'avais un pote qui était déjà
dans le placard depuis 15 ans qui m'a
bien aidé. Euh il y en avait
quelques-uns. Euh bon leur leur objectif
en fait était de faire sortir les gens
qui étaient un peu trop réticents les
uns après les autres avec ces fameuses
clauses de silence et de l'argent. Et
d'ailleurs, ça a marché un jour Reporter
sans frontière a évalué qu'à peu près il
y avait en France aujourd'hui dans le
plus grand secret à peu près 800
journalistes qui auraient signé ces
clauses de silence euh pour se faire
bayonner. Alors après côté canal, ils
disent bah ouais mais tu avais qu'à pas
signer. Ben bon alors d'accord. Sauf
qu'en fait il faut savoir que quand tu
es dans une boîte que tu es en CDI, que
tu as des momes à nourrir et que on te
dit parce que moi moi je leur dis mais
sortez-moi dans un plan social avec le
minimum. Je m'en fous moi du fric, c'est
pas le sujet. Laissez-moi sortir avec
juste de quoi retomber sur mes pades
pour mes gamins quoi. Et en fait, ils te
disent non mais tu veux le plan social,
tu veux sortir ? OK mais faut signer
l'accord, faut signer l'accord de
sidence sinon tu sors pas. et tu es tu
es tenu puis après les mecs qui
t'attendent pendant 5 ans, ils
t'attendent la faute. Donc tu dis [__]
le moindre truc, je vais faire une
connerie, je vais pas me rendre compte,
ils vont me fumer pour faute comme ils
ont fait avec le patron du zapping. Tu
sors, tu as rien quoi. Donc c'est un peu
délicat comme situation quoi. Donc mais
voilà, enfin au-delà de mon cas, il y a
800 personnes dans cette situation en
France qui se taisent aujourd'hui, qui
peuvent même pas dire j'ai signé une
clause de silence parce que s'ils le
disent même euh voilà, ils doivent
rendre la tune. Donc il a acheté une
ORTA en fait. Euh Boloré, voilà.
Enfin investigation, vous traitez quoi ?
On traite quoi ? Bah en fait après cette
sortie de canal après 5 ans, l'idée
c'est de se dire bah on doit pouvoir
traiter ce qui nous paraît intéressant
quoi. Donc moi je sais pas ce qu'on
traite. D'ailleurs, pas que moi qui
décide he c'est une petite équipe, les
gens peuvent avoir leurs idées, ils
arrivent avec des trucs machin, mais on
veut pouvoir traiter ce qui nous paraît
intéressant avec le temps pour le faire.
On a pas envie d'être speed parce qu'un
des pièges de la presse, c'est la
vitesse. Moi, je vois plein de confrères
pris dans la le speed, des chaînes
d'infos, des machins. Alors, on se dit
alors soit soit soit il bossent trop
vite, soit c'est pas de leur faute, les
pauvres, on les fait bosser vite et
cetera. Mais à un moment donné dans ce
métier, faut savoir dire "Attendez,
stop, moi je vais pas prendre la parole
publiquement, engager une image sur un
truc que j'ai pas pu vérifier, ça
suffit." Donc faut du temps quoi déjà.
Donc courir après l'actu, le speed, j'ai
sorti le truc avant le voisin, c'est une
connerie déjà. Donc il y a ça euh donc
prendre du temps euh éviter toute
interférence des annonceurs
publicitaires, de l'État, des
actionnaires machin. Donc dire à la
population de ce pays, il faut que vous
contribuiez à renouveler le système
informationnel. Et moi ce qui me fait
plaisir tous les jours, c'est qu'en fait
les gens sont tellement écœurés par le
fait que le système informationnel en
France est malade euh pétite conflit
d'intérêt en permanence que les gens
sont massivement écœurés qui commencent
à le comprendre et que donc voilà il y a
il y a des gens qui ont pas de tunes he
en France. Nous on a des petits
retraités qui nous filent de trois
balles. Mais en vrai, il y a quand même
70 millions de personnes. Enfin, nous on
nâche pas 30000 citoyens qui nous ontidé
depuis le début. Bah, on a réussi à
faire 20 documentaire d'investigation.
Donc, en fait, on n'est pas très cher en
fait nos médias. On n'est pas on
s'achète pas des yautes, on n pas des
bagnoles machin, tu vois, ça va. Donc en
fait, on peut faire de l'information
correctement. Alors après, on aimerait
bien avoir un peu plus de dons pour
payer un peu mieux nos nos salariés et
cetera, mais on peut bosser en fait. On
est en train de renouveler quelque chose
comme vous faites, comme d'autres font.
Et euh et moi je pense queon est en
train de d'embêter le système et ça fait
quand même plaisir parce que tous ces
puissances industrielles ou ces
politiques ont essayé de prendre le
contrôle des grandes marques
d'information crédibles auprès des
citoyens en disant bah si on contrôle on
contrôle tout. En fait ils ont pris une
contrôle de 90 %. Sauf que dans un
système totalitaire quand tu as un grain
de sable [rires] ça fout un bordel noir.
Par exemple Xavier Niel dit à la
commission de l'audiosel public je peux
pas j'ai un truc à l'étranger, je peux
pas. Nous on s'amuse, on apprend qu'il a
courch chevel, on révèle qu'il a courch
chevel.
Ça nous fait marrer, ça fait péter sa
communication. Tout le monde se marre.
Merde, il était au ski. Bon, donc en
fait voilà, c'est c'est si tu veux
contrôler un système informationnel et
des cerveaux, il faut pas qu'il y ait
des emmerdeurs, quoi. Et donc moi, je
pense que les médias indé qu'on présente
ou d'autres en fait en fait on a beau
être petit euh potentiellement on est un
caillou dans la chaussure de certaines
personnes quoi. Donc
qui dit caillou dit ciblage. Est-ce que
investigation a été ciblée par des
campagnes de presse calomnieuses ?
Est-ce que tu as eu des procès ? que tu
as fait
alors pas tellement au début parce que
quand tu commences, tu es un clown et
tout le monde se marre quoi. Après euh
on a un peu le sentiment qu'on monte un
petit peu en puissance parce que les
documentaires d'investigation qu'on
faisait au début faisait 200000 vues,
après 1 million de vues, là on en a un
qui a 4 millions de vues. Donc en terme
d'impact pour comparer hein, bon un cash
d'investigation qui cartonne, ça va être
3 millions de personnes. Un complément
qui complément enquête qui cartonne,
c'est à peu près 2 millions de
personnes. Donc quand on fait des doc à
4 millions, bah en fait en terme
d'impact waouh, ça ça pèse quoi. Et un
complément d'enquête c'est 120000 €.
Nous on coûte nous on arrive à le
fabriquer à 40000. Bon 40 50 et cetera
et en fait on a de l'impact. Donc ça,
moi je sens que là il y a un truc qu'on
va commencer à être en danger parce
qu'en fait on fait chier quoi. Et à un
moment donné, il va nous arriver des
trucs. Donc bon là on a eu ce qu'on a un
peu perçu comme une campagne hostile en
janvier de la part de Street Press qui
est qui nous a dit ben en fait sur vos
votre quinzaine de journalistes
qui se trouvait plutôt majoritairement
de sensibilité de gauche, ils ont trouvé
qu'il y en avait trois qui avaient
peut-être d'après eux une sensibilité
plus à droite voir l'extrême droite. Ils
ont trouvé ça scandaleux. Donc ils nous
ont
c'est interdit du journalistes de
droite.
Euh
bah après ça dépend ça dépend ce que ça
veut dire mais en tout cas pour Street
Press ça posé un problème euh comment
dire il y a eu un peu un bon ça nous a
un peu bousculé au festigation parce
qu'on n'est pas tous d'accord il y a des
il y a des jeunes il y a des gens plus
vieux et cetera donc ça ça a créé un peu
de d'émotion.
Il y a eu un peu de de logiques qui se
sont qui se qui se sont mis à dialoguer.
C'estàd que moi j'ai un peu j'essaie un
peu de me dire "OK, ce qu'il faut c'est
donner au public de ce pays les
informations les plus vérifiées, les
plus rigoureuses et les plus
intéressantes possible pour l'intérêt
général et je vais pas forcément
chercher dans le cerveau de la personne
qui m'amène l'info tant qu'elle bosse
sérieusement pour qui elle vote ce
qu'elle pense c'est ce qu'elle a fait il
y a 30 ans et puis c'est pas enfin j'ai
pas le droit non plus d'aller fouiller
dans les cerveaux et puis une autre
partie de l'équipe peut-être plus jeune
qui était plus en mode un peu un peu
flippé il faut faire attention au profil
politique des contributeurs." Bon, donc
c'est un débat complexe hein. Voilà.
Mais pour donner par exemple un exemple,
un des jouristes pointés par Street
Press, Olivier Nikini m'avait proposé il
y a 2 ou 3 ans une série sur Gabriel
Matsnef. Matsnef, c'est un intellectuel
flamboyant des années 80 qui a défendu
la pédocriminalité sur tous les plateaux
et qui était très en cours en France
dans cette époque-là, une époque où une
partie très en cours en France et du
côté de quel cours ? Alors dans les
médias très en cours dans
l'intelligencia parisienne d'ailleurs de
droite et de gauche, il était pote avec
Le Pen et avec Miton donc si tu veux
voilà
et Matznef racontait sur tous les
plateaux que en gros il avait des
petites copines de 14 ans et il disait
dans ses carnets que en Asie il allait
avoir des rapports sexuels avec des
gamins de 7 ans. Et à l'époque, ça peut
paraître étonnant aujourd'hui mais ça
passait. Il éta invité chez pivot tout
ça. On rigolait 14 ans machin. Bon en
fait c'est un un dangereux pédo
criminel, un gros pédo criminel grave
quoi. Mais il était partout sur les
plateaux et cetera. Donc ce journaliste
30 ans après me dit c'est marrant, il a
écrit dans des carnés l'intégralité de
ce qu'il a fait pendant 20 ans. Il a
tout raconté. Les mecs qui
connaissaient, les mecs importants, les
mecs connus qui étaient les les gamins
en Asie. Il raconte qu'il va avoir des
des enfin violer des momes de 7 ans. Il
leur donne un poulet à la fin pour les
nourrir. Il est content. Le mec, il
marque ça dans ses carnets. C'est
tellement gênant les carnets sortis chez
Galimar pendant 20 ans que Galimar
commence à les planquer. On les trouve
plus, c'est chaud parce que aujourd'hui
ça passe plus. Ce journaliste me dit
"Ben moi, j'ai retrouvé plein de carnet
Madnef, ça m'intéresse. Je suis dedans
depuis 6 mois, je vais faire je vais
faire à travers les carnet, je vais
faire le portrait d'une époque et d'une
complaisance pédocriminelle qui qui a pu
exister en France. C'est intéressant.
Bon, le mec je sens qu'il est pas
forcément très de gauche. Je le connais
pas mais je prends son truc parce que
c'est bien. Puis je je m'assure aussi
qu'il prend les carnets Madsnef et qu'il
prend pas enfin il part pas non plus en
en délire quoi. Il livre une série
d'articles pas mal. 3 ans après Street
Prince nous dit "Oh là là ! Oui mais il
collabore avec cause d'Élisabeth Levi
donc c'est un islamophobe." Alors je dis
alors attendez stop connais pas
spécialement Cervette Levi. Je crois
qu'elle a fait le tour de tous les
médias français Elizabeth Lévi. Elle a
créé un site qui s'appelle Cauzer qui
peut-être n'aime pas trop l'islam. Euh
enfin chacun sa ligne éditoriale et euh
et je vois pas le sujet mais en gros la
critique larvée de street press c'est
donc vous serez islamophobe. Alors enfin
c'est c'est lunaire en fait parce que
enfin moi j'ai passé 10 ans à bosser sur
la seule guerre algérienne. On m'a
traité d'islamiste. Maintenant je serai
islamophobe. Enfin on se pince quoi.
Donc il y a un moment donné c'est
compliqué. Dans cette affaire par
exemple je considère que la série
Mazzef, elle elle est elle est utile,
elle est remarquable. La question de la
pédocriminalité, elle est dans
l'actualité. Ça dérange aussi les intell
de gauche parce qu'il y a quand même un
paquet de gens qui ont été complaisants
avec la pédocriminalité dans les années
80.
participer
Jacquelang Kouchner enfin plein de gens
ont pris des positions c'est prouvé ou
pas ?
Bah il y a plein d'exemples. Con Benit
il fait un bouquin pour dire que c'est
la musée avec les gamins de des
Braguettes. Jacques Lang et Kouchner il
signent une tribune dans le monde à la
fin des années 70 pour dire il y a trois
pédophiles en prison c'est quand même
scandaleux faut les sortir. Polac il a
raconté
donc ils ont pas participé.
Non non alors je dis pas que c'est non
je parle pas d'intellectuel de gauche
pédophile. Je dis juste qu'il y a eu
dans une époque post 68 et ça peut se
comprendre parce que dans une époque où
en gros avant 68 les femmes ont pas le
droit de mettre des pantalons et et les
vieux de la vieille qui on fait la
résistance et qui ont pris le pouvoir en
France oppresse tout le monde. C'est
c'est des vieux mâles qui font chier.
Donc plus personne n'a le droit de rien
faire. Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe en 68
? Les vieux arrêter de nous faire chier.
On a le droit d'interdit d'interdire. On
a le droit de faire l'amour. Jouir sans
entrave et tout ce que tu veux. Moi, je
pense qu'il y a une libération de 68 qui
est souhaitable et et positive parce que
parce queil y avait probablement une
oppression de voilà des générations les
plus âgées sur la jeunesse et que la
jeunesse se révolte par par épisode et
que c'est normal et que c'est sain et
foutez-nous la paix et la pilule et
l'avortement et cetera. Donc d'énormes
progrès sauf qu'il y a une partie de de
de cette révolution sexuelle en fait qui
a été un peu plus loin qui a été jusqu'à
dire et puis après tout, je vois pas
pourquoi on pourrait pas prendre du
plaisir avec un enfant de 12 ans et lui
apprendre l'amour. Bon. Ah oui, c'est ça
ce qui a été dit par un certain nombre
de gens, pas tout le monde. Bon, mais
ils ont pas dit plus tard que c'était
une connerie de signer cette tribune.
Bah, ils sont emmerdés parce que il y a
il y a 30 mais il y a Jean-Paul Sart.
Enfin, ils sont 30 he la tribune du
monde en 78 je crois. Il y a 30
intellectuels qui disent "C'est trois
pauvres pédophiles en prison quand même,
on criminalise l'amour, ça va pas." Bonà
donc après coup, ils étaient un peu
emmerdés mais enfin ils l'ont signé, ils
peuvent rien dire. Et il y a un journal
qui était encore beaucoup plus loin dans
dans ça, c'est Libération que moi j'ai
apprécié pendant des années, que j'ai
beaucoup lu, j'étais abonné, j'aimais
bien libéré.
La fameuse la fameuse photo noir et
blanc là. Bah entre autres, c'est qu'il
y a oui, ils vont publier des textes en
défense d'un type qui est vraiment un
pédocriminel dangereux. Ils vont alors
ce dessin lunaire dont on parle, enfin
là on n'est pas avec des images, mais en
fait ils vont publier un dessin euh en
gros du sexe d'un homme avec la tête
d'un gamin qui est collé au sex genre
apprenons l'amour à nos enfants. Donc ça
va quand même super loin et il y a une
époque où une partie de l'intelligence
de ce pays a considéré qu'il fallait
libérer les enfants, leur permettre de
faire l'amour à 8 ans et que c'était une
entrave insupportable de les emmerder.
Bon, c'est lunaire. En vérité, c'était
des adultes qui étaient dans leur toute
puuissance, des hommes et qui voulaient
juste assurer leur plaisir sans limite,
jouir sans entrave. He, c'est quand même
ça. Et donc, ils ont abîmé, massacré pas
mal d'enfants. Donc, après 40 ans après,
ça ressort. Le bouquin de Camille
Kouchner, la familière grandé et cetera
sur du hamel. Ça ressort chez Vanessa
Springora, une ancienne petite amie de
Maznef qui raconte à quel point c'était
n'importe quoi et cetera. Bon,
aujourd'hui, on a le le neveu de de
Gérard Louvin qui rencontre une vie de
de harcèlement en tant qu'enfant. On
sort une interview en ce moment surf, le
neveu de Louvin qui raconte une époque
lunaire. Louvin, c'est le principal
producteur de diversement de TF1 pendant
20 ans. Il fait sacrée soirée et à
chaque fois que sa cré soirée c'est
fini, il part à sa baraque de Sèvre avec
son petit euh neveu qui a 8 ou 10 ou 12
ans et il se passe des trucs de dingue.
Donc il y a une époque qui a vraiment
déconné quoi. Qui a vraiment déconné.
Bon donc tout ça pour
tout ça c'est sourcé. Bah ouais, enfin
ça fait on a déjà diffusé dans un
documentaire en septembre cette histoire
et on a refait de manière approfondie le
neveu de Louvin là qui est en diffusion
sur notre site. On l'a laissé parler une
demi-heure parce que c'est lunaire quoi.
Et euh et et Louvin a aucun moment de
l'a attaqué en diffamation parce que de
toute façon euh enfin il sait très bien
que c'est vrai. Il a été entendu par les
brigades des Mineurs en 2014. Ils ont
fait un standom d'au. Alors c'est
prescrit parce que ça fait 30 ans donc
Louvin Penard. Il va faire le nouvel an
en Brésil avec son son mari et pénard.
Mais en vrai ouais ça a gravement
déconné. à Grédano rebalance grave chez
nous et euh et voilà. Et donc tout ça
pour dire que euh quand on m'amène une
série sur Madnef d'un mec qui a plongé
pendant 6 mois dans la carnet Madnef qui
a fait 80 pages, qui trouve pas
d'éditeur mais qui a fait un boulot
sérieux, moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant. Ça raconte une époque.
Voilà 3 ans après, on vient nous dire
"Ouais mais le mec OK, il est chez
Ellisabeth LVI donc il est de droite
donc ça va pas." Voilà après il y a eu
un gros débat dans l'équipe, il y a eu
discussion, il y a eu arbitrage. Moi je
suis pas un tirant, je décide pas tout.
Voilà, on a fait des choix, on on a
décidé de de fonctionner un peu
différemment. a venir. Mais euh mais
oui, on a perçu un peu ça de la part de
Street Press comme une campagne.
D'autant que moi je connaissais pas très
bien ce site. Alors de mon point de vue,
il faut un boulot utile sur euh les
violences policières et parfois sur
l'extrême droite mais en même temps ils
ont des papiers qui expliquent que de
Sahal l'armée israélienne c'est super.
Alors, c'est des papiers qui datent
parfois de 2011-212, certes, mais il y a
un truc très bizarre sur ce site, c'est
que dans les papiers qui font la
promotion de salle dans dans avec un
intérêt journalistique assez évanescent,
tu as au milieu souvent un titre un un
lien au fait pour contacter de salle,
cliquez ici. Alors, tu dis attends euh
faut savoir que street press à
l'origine, c'est pas un site
d'information, c'est une agence de
communication pour les entreprises. Les
six premières années, ils font que du
contenu public rédactionnel pour les
boîtes, je sais pas quoi. Il y a pas
l'idée d'avoir ni un abonné, ni un
donateur, ni rien du tout pendant 6 ou 7
années. Et donc maintenant, ils font des
dons pour dire "Mais si, on a des dons
et cera". Mais d'origine, c'est plutôt
un truc de com pour les entreprises. Ils
font du publ reportage assumé. Et
là-dessus, tu as des papiers pour Tshal
un peu bizarre. Ah, Tshal va faire un
nouveau site pour communiquer en
français. Pour contacter Tshal, cliquez
ici. Ah, c'est touristes français qui
vont faire des vacances chez cette salle
en colonie de vacances là-bas au milieu
des chars et des canons. C'est rigolo tu
te pinces quoi. Donc bon, enfin voilà.
Donc moi je pense qu'on aurait pu
regarder attentivement leur ligne
éditoriale et la questionner franchement
et nous on leur dit quand il nous
accrochent avec ça, on leur dit bah
regardez notre ligne éditoriale,
regardez nos contenus et parlez-nous de
nos contenus. Et ils ont rien sur nos
contenus donc ils vont chercher. Oui
mais lui ensuite 2 ans après, il a été
bossé chez chez cause bon enfin pardon
c'est interdit ou c'est un problème
politique et puis qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans son cerveau ? Puis je sais pas tant
que tu es dans son cerveau. Enfin bon
donc voilà. Après
quel est le doc qui a le mieux mieux
fonctionné sur votre plateforme ?
Alors euh dès la première saison en 2021
2022, on est au moment de la
présidentielle, on va faire 6 ou 7 doc
bilan du quinquena Macron.
Euh le patrimoine de Macron où sont
partis les millions va faire un carton.
Il est aujourd'hui à 3200000 vues. Donc
on a on a travaillé sur le patrimoine du
président parce qu'il y avait deux trois
conneries. Tu veux que je te raconte ?
Tu crois que tu es venu pour pousser un
cad ou quoi ? Ouais,
[raclement de gorge]
vas-y.
Non, le patrimoine du président, je l'ai
fait avec un jeune journaliste Gautier
Vestier. Le patrimoine du président en
fait, alors il y a un euh il était il
devait être parfaitement assujetti à à
l'ISF dès bien avant 2012 parce que
Brigitte Macon avait une maison assez
chère au Toutai. lui s'était acheté un
appartement assez cher dans le 15e. Donc
le tout si tu veux dépasser le le
montant de la l'impôt sur la fortune.
Euh ce que nous expliquer longuement un
jour du Canal enchaîné qui a enquêé
là-dessus, c'est que Macron a pendant
des années s'est démerdé pour faire une
déclaration de patrimoine où il
diminuait la valeur de ses biens pour
passer juste en dessous de l'ISF. Alors,
on se dit c'est bizarre de faire tout ça
pour économiser 6000 balles parce que
l'ISF en fait si tu es juste au-dessus
c'est pas très cher. Et le le confrère
du Canard nous disait "Non mais c'est
pas pour 6000 balles. C'est pas ça le
problème. C'est que Macron c'est un
libéral qui vient de la banque
Rothschield qui est un conseiller de
Hollande, on est en 2011. Rothseld le
symbole. Donc Macron, il faut surtout
pas qu'on dise Macron il paye des SF en
fait. Comment tu veux monter en
politique dans un environnement de
centre-gauche si tu payes l'ISF Donc
Macron, il avait un problème d'image.
Donc il a il s'est démerdé pour ne pas
payer l'ISF pendant des années et
d'ailleurs il a même été à France 2 pour
dire "Oui, regardez moi, je suis une
riche machin, je paye pas l'ISF et
cetera." Bon, manque de bol à un moment
donné, il est rattrapé par la patrouille
parce que les mecs de Ber attends ta
baraque, elle vaut pas 1 million, elle
vaut unlion4 machin, ils font les
calculs, paf, rattrapé par la
patrouille, 3 ans de retard, 3 ans de
pénalité, il doit payer et euh bon donc
il paye pe importe quelques milliers
d'euros mais surtout la vérité sort en
fait oui, il était assujetti à l'USF, il
aurait dû le payer et donc quand il est
élu président 2017 et qui va le
supprimer qui t'a créé la colère des
gilets jaunes, bah les gens disent ah
bah oui mais en fait il a suppriméf pour
faire plaisir à ses potes qui avait
beaucoup d'argent mais aussi parce que
enfin lui quelque part le SF Ça l'a fait
chier pendant des années. Bon, puis un
autre exemple, Brigitte lui a prêté
300000 € il a oublié de le dire dans sa
déclaration. Et troisème truc le plus
important,
ils étaient mariés.
Ah ouais ? Ouais, ils étaient mariés.
Ouais. Et Brigitte, elle a le droit de
c'est pas de prêter, c'est le couple,
c'est la même déclaration fiscale.
Oui. Oui. Mais les les avocats
fiscalistes qu'on a questionné nous ont
expliqué longuement qu'en fait oui, ton
épouse peut te faire un prêt. N'empêche
que ça rentre dans ton patrimoine
en tant que prêt et tu peux pas faire
semblant que ça n'est pas arrivé. Enfin,
il y a un truc un peu compliqué mais
les acquis ils sont Tu connais le
contrat de mariage ?
Non.
Ah, ce serait bien peut-être.
Bah écoute, on avait beaucoup bossé,
c'était en 2021. On a on avait tourné le
problème dans tous les sens, on avait
questionné Macron là-dessus. Tous les
experts ficialistes nous disaient "Ce
prêt ne peut pas être invisibilisé.
C'est pas parce que c'est son mari et sa
femme que que 350000 bas ça existe pas."
Enfin bon, on pourrait replonger dans le
détail. Le doc est en ligne he mais ils
ont jamais protesté. Tout était bon. Et
et troisème élément le le plus important
euh il y a un truc très étrange quand
Macron donc va passer 3 ans à la banque
Rcheld, il va gagner à peu près 3
millions d'euros entre 2008 et 2012.
brute,
je crois que c'est 3 millions d'euros
dans sa poche. Après, il y a des impôts.
Euh mais en gros, c'est une somme quand
même assez significative qui faisait
dire à Olivier Berruer de de Lucide, bah
le mec c'est bizarre parce que quand il
arrive en 2012, je crois, il dit "Bah
non, moi j'ai plus rien, j'ai pas de
patrimoine." Donc ça voudrait dire qu'il
a claqué un SMIC par jour pendant 3 ans.
C'est fameuse calcul qui avait fait
Berruer donc c'était un peu bizarre.
Puis Macron dit "Oui, oui, j'ai
dépensé." Bon bref, OK. Mais c'est même
pas ça le problème. En fait, il a gagné
officiellement 3 millions d'euros chez
Rothild. Mais c'est surtout qu'en fait
en 2012, Macron va faire un deal
absolument majeur au sein de la banque
Rothild parce que la division nutrition
infantile de l'américain euh euh Pfizer
va être mise en vente. Et il y a deux
géants qui veulent attraper la division
nutrition infantile de Pfizer. C'est
d'un côté Nestley les Suisses, de
l'autre côté Danon les Français.
Macron est à l'époque associé gérant de
la banque Rotchild. Euh et il va essayer
de de de d'aider euh Nestley à attraper
euh Pfizer. [grognement]
Il va essayer d'aider. Tu as des preuves
? C'est des suputations ?
Non non, c'est c'est public. Il a il a
été missionné par la banque Chile dans
cette affaire. Il l'a euh ça a été
longuement raconté dans le détail. Il a
il était devenu pote avec le patron
Nestley, un autrichien alpiniste, Peter
Brabec à la commission à en 2008. Donc
quand il découvre que Nestley est sur
les les rang avec Danon pour racheter
Pfizer, c'est dédi deal à 10 milliards
d'euros. Brac, c'est celui qui veut
privatiser l' potable. Non, c'est pas
lui.
Alors, je sais pas, c'est le patron de
Nesley à l'époque. Donc, on est en 2012.
Je sais pas s'il a toujours, je je sais
pas. Mais en tout cas, donc il y a deux
géants qui veulent acheter Pfizer 10
milliards d'euros, je te dis pas la
commission pour la banque d'affaires qui
fait le deal. Il y a deux banques
d'affaires sur les rangs. Il y a Lazar
d'un côté, Rchill de l'autre. Macron, il
est côté Rchill, sauf que Rchill, ils
sont pas spécialement maqués avec les
les acteurs en jeu. Donc, c'est pas
simple. Sauf que Macron connaît bien le
patron de Nestley parce qu'il l'a connu
la commission Atalie. Donc Macron va se
faire présenter le directeur juridique
de Nestley et va un weekend stratégique
où Nestley et Danon sont en train
quasiment de conclure, on parle de
milliards d'euros. Macron saute dans un
avion, on va voir le patron Nestley en
Suisse à Vevet euh et lui dit "Si vous
mettez 500 millions d'euros de plus sur
la table, je suis sûr que vous rafle les
trucs. On est à la bab de Danon." Le mec
dit "OK, mais 500 millions, paf, c'est
Nesle qui remporte l'affaire." C'est un
deal absolument majeur. Et il y a un
truc très bizarre, c'est que c'est un
deal donc de de 10 à 11 milliards
d'euros qui va être conclu à peu près en
mai 2012. Et juste après, il arrive à
l'Élysée, Macron, il devient donc le je
crois que directeur adjoint de cabinet,
attends, comment on appelle ça ?
Secrétaire général adjoint de l'Élysée
sous Hollande mai 2012. OK. Sauf qu'il
vient de faire, il vient d'avoir une
contribution déterminante dans un deal
majeur. Il est associé Géril. Il a
personnellement convaincu Brabec de
mettre l'argent. Il s'est extrêmement
impliqué. Et donc tout ça pour dire que
il va déclarer cette année-là à peu près
700000 € de revenu. [grognement] Euh or
tous les experts nous disent mais un
deal à 10 milliards, la banque
d'affaires qui a conclu deal prend des
sommes infiniment supérieures. Alors
attention, c'est pas Macron, c'est pas
voilà, c'est pas Macron qui prend la
tune, c'est la banque Rilde.
C'est des trucs très opaques, on sait
pas combien ils ont pris. Ils ont ils
ont dans toutes les coutumes bancaires
qu'on nous a raconté, on prend des
sommes beaucoup plus importants. Sur 10
milliards d'euros, ça va être plutôt de
l'ordre. pas, on est sur 100, 200, 300
millions, on n'est pas sur 700000 mal et
et Macron lui, il déclare 700000. Bon,
donc tous les observateurs nous disent,
tous les milieux d'affaires savent très
bien qu'en fait alors soit il a bossé
gratos, bon peut-être, soit l'argent il
l'a pas déclaré quoi. Donc ça c'est un
truc le plus important, le plus
mystérieux sur lequel on a essayé de
travailler. C'est pas simple, on est un
petit médien indépendant, on n pas trop
de sous, on a essayé de gratter. On
pense nous que là il y a un loup, il y a
un truc, il y a quelque chose. Bon donc
on a voilà si tu te trompes.
Mais non c'est pas constrom c'est on
Est-ce que tu as essayé de penser contre
toi-même ?
Tout le temps. Tout le temps. Mais si tu
veux euh
une
un bonbon.
Ouais. [rires]
Non c'est pas comment dire bien sûr
qu'on veut pas se tromper. Bien sûr
qu'on fait attention, mais il y a un
moment donné si tu veux enfin
tout le monde sait que tout le monde
sait que des deals de cette importance
Tout le monde sait que des deals de
cette importance donnent lieu à des
pourcentages assez habituels pour les
banques d'affaires. Alors ça peut être 1
% 2 % 2 % mais c'est pas 0,01 % ça
n'existe pas. Bon Macron déclare un
montant de de d'honoraire cette année-là
qui n'est pas cohérent. Je me suis dit
peut-être que ça lui a été versé en
2013, on a retrouvé sa déclaration de
machin 2013. Non, il y a rien. 2013, il
dit "Je suis secrétaire général adjoint
de l'Élysée, je gagne pas grand-chose."
Bon, donc il y a un problème. Donc à
partir de là, on se dit y a un truc qui
colle pas comme plein d'avocats
fiscalistes et plein de gens qui
regardent qui disent "Ça va pas, on
retrouve un ancien proche de la proche
de la banquield, également proche de
Macron qui nous dit a y a il y a un loup
quoi ?" Voilà. Donc
je peux me faire l'avocat du diable ?
Ouais.
Est-ce que tu as essayé de te dire
peut-être il me raconte la vérité et
peut-être qu'on est en train de le faire
chier pour rien.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais dans ce cas-là,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Première chose
qu'on fait, il y a deux organismes mises
en cause. Il y a un monsieur qui
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron, il y a une
manquantill. Bon ben voilà, on contacte
la manquant chill dans toute bonne fois
en disant voilà, on a le temps, on n'est
pas speed, on fait un truc, on a trouvé
ça, il y a un truc bizarre. Quel est le
montant de votre deal ? Et est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire à peu près combien
touche votre associé gérant qui fait le
deal ? Bon, silence radio. On pareil
avec l'Élysée, évidemment. On contacte
l'Élysée cher monsieur voilà il y a ce
truc là machin on est très étonné par la
disproportion des sommes. Est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer quelqu'un pas
forcément vous, vous avez pas le temps
un chargé de com quelqu'un personne
silence radio total. OK.
Donc nous on se dit dans ce casl B on
aimerait bien être un peu moins seul
aussi à gratter sur ce sujet pourquoi
après tout des médias qui 300
journalistes des subventions publiques
et cera se mettent pas à travailler
là-dessus. Bon pourquoi le monde
travaille pas sur Macron ? Enfin il
travaille sur Macron je pas critiquer
les confrères mais il y a des médias
plus puissants qui pourrait aussi
critiquer les confrères.
Non mais je moi je suis un peu énervé
par le système informationnel français
donc des fois je suis un peu je suis un
peu un peu un peu excessif quoi. Il y a
des très bons journalistes partout je
pas c'est pas parce qu'ils ont des
propriétaires
qui parfois prennent le contrôle de
médias pour pour les instrumentaliser
voir dans certains cas faire de la
propagande que forcément les confrères
ou les consœurs sont sont pourris. Enfin
c'est plus compliqué que ça.
Je je peux ouvrir une une parenthèse
dans la parenthèse.
Comment formuler ça sans heurter trop
les oreilles ?
en face le public qui commence à un peu
ralbol des journalistes qui font des
ménages, des journalistes qui ciblent
pour faire terre des campagnes de de
presse pour défoncer la réputation des
on l'a subi. Donc la question que je te
pose en tant que journaliste qu'on
respecte parce que tu es tu es là, il en
a pas beaucoup.
Admettons que tu travailles dans une
boîte où il y a beaucoup de journalistes
qui n'ont pas de réflexe de du moins qui
ont un réflexe de déglition très
prononcé.
Si nous on commence à se fâcher et qu'on
veut dire que tu es une perte
collatérale au milieu du nombre de
journalistes qui avalent des couleuvres
et que tant pis, tu vas passer avec mais
on on n'est pas content donc tu es une
perte collatérale pour nous même si tu
es bon il faut que la caste
gère les mauvais qui souillent votre
profession si honorable
Parce que on voit pas de journalistes
qui enquêtent sur des journalistes pour
savoir s'ils font des ménages. Pas
souvent ça arrive ça. Il y a un peu un
phénomène de cast. On se protège, on
espère une place, on Non, tu as vu ça ?
Alors
tu réponds sinon ta vène tu veux la
valaller de travers dans pas longtemps.
[rires]
C'est moi qui vais pas taper dans la
gueule.
Ouais. Alors méfie-toi parce que j'en ai
calmé. Ouais, j'en ai calmé des des plus
véments que toi.
Bon, attends, je prendre un peu de recul
parce que moi je suis journaliste, donc
je suis un peu dans la dans la casse.
Mais juste un truc, je pense qu'on fait
un métier où c'est quand même compliqué
euh
[gémissement]
d'aller manger tous les jours.
Là, on fait on fait un boulot public et
on essaie de trouver des faits, de les
vérifier. Bon, donc
est-ce que tu as compris ma question ?
Oui. Non, mais je comprends.
Est-ce que tu peux reformuler ma
question pour savoir si tu l'as bien
comprise ? Non, je vais te dire, je
pense que j'ai pas envie d'attaquer des
des gens, mais je pense qu'il y a un
problème dans la propriété des médias en
France. À partir du moment où l'État
contrôle de manière étroite et Macron le
fait depuis la fin de leurance de
manière étroite puisque tous les ans les
patrones de l'elé public doivent venir
supplier pour avoir un budget et que ça
c'est pas possible en fait depuis la fin
de la redevance et que dans le privé 5
milliardaires ont pris le contrôle de 90
% des marques crédibles qui avaient été
créées par des gens qui bossaient pour
un peu trop souvent les instrumentaliser
ou ne pas traiter certains sujets et
cetera. Voilà. Et ben tout le système
est gangrainé en fait,
profondémentrainé. C'est des millions de
gens qui s'informment par des médias
profondément gangrenés dans lesquels il
y a parfois des bons journalistes qui
font parfois du bon boulot. C'est pas su
collatéral.
On a un problème de gangrenage général.
Voilà. Donc à partir de là, il faut
sortir de ce système et de l'influence
de l'État et de l'influence de puissance
actionnaires pour refonder les médias
ind. Il y a pas le choix. Voilà. Donc à
partir de là, nous c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire. Moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il y
a une colère de la population de ce pays
contre les journalistes parce que 70 %
des gens croient plus les journalistes.
Il y a un sujet. Moi, j'ai poussé un
coup de gueule au Sénat il y a 15 jours
en disant "Mais vous vous rendez compte,
c'est lunaire. 70 % des gens de ce pays
croient plus les journalistes.
C'est quoi ta source 70 % ?"
Alors, on m'a répondu, une sénatrice m'a
dit "Oui, j'ai vu le sondage, c'est 65
%. Il y a un truc de télérerama tous les
ans qui regarde la confiance des
Français dans la presse." Alors, je
connais pas le dernier chiffre, mais
c'est systématiquement depuis plusieurs
années une majorité de gens qui ne
croient plus les journalistes. Bon, donc
tu es sénateur, tu es parlementaire dans
ce pays, tu te tu réveilles qu'il y a un
problème. Tu te dis "Il y a quelque
chose qui va pas ou quoi et c'est pas
une question de taper sur un tel ou sur
un tel."
Les gens ont le sentiment, enfin c'est
pas le sentiment, enfin moi-même je
regarde la télé enfin toute la journée,
je me dis mais c'est la propagande en
fait massivement beaucoup tout le temps,
il y a tout le temps des trucs foireux,
pas honnêtes, pas clair. Je sais pas,
enfin je prends l'exemple de de de Gaza.
On a l'impression que les palestiniens
sont des animaux qu'on peut taper
dessus, qu'on peut mitrailler des gamins
avec des drones avec des balles dans les
yeux, ça pose pas de problème. Mais
100000 morts, enfin je veux dire c'est
quoi ce délire quoi ? 100000 morts.
Enfin bon, je je vais m'énerver donc je
vais m'arrêter. Mais c'est pour dire que
vieillage
vas-y.
On ne m on m souvent lors de la chasse
et de la guerre ou après la chasse ou
après la guerre ou pendant la guerre.
Donc je demande à me faire fa checker
retrouver mon programme.
Donc c'est normal qu'il mente.
Non c'est parce que c'est la guerre ça
monte.
Oui oui bien sûr. C'est la propagande de
guerre. Non mais d'accord, mais si tu
veux, le problème c'est que euh moi
quand j'allume ma télé ou j'allume ma
radio, je suis pas là pour avoir la
propagande, quoi. Je veux dire, ou alors
je sais pas pourquoi je paye ma
redevance et je sais pas pourquoi je me
je me tape l'émission que je me paye.
Quo
le proverbe c'est on ne m jamais tant
qu'avant les élections, pendant la
guerre et après la chasse.
OK, donc ça m massivement. OK, ça se
voit un peu trop. Donc moi ça m'énerve
parce que moi quand je prends du temps
pour écouter un journaliste, c'est pas
pour qu'il me mente. Moi j'allume pas un
propagandiste quand j'allume la télé,
j'allume un journaliste. Donc c'est
c'est constant, c'est permanent. Il y a
des tas de sujets qui sont invisibilisés
mais discrètement, c'est très insidieux,
on te le dit pas évidemment. Donc les
gens qui ont pas toute la journée pour
s'informer, voir qu'on les enfle,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils vont taffer
la journée, le soir, ils sont fatigués,
ils ont besoin d'avoir un peu les infos
en un quart d'heure, ils allument ce
qu'ils allument et puis il gobent ce qu'
gob. Ils ont pas forcément l'expertise
pour s'apercevoir qu'on est en train de
les entuber. Donc moi ça m'énerve, ça me
rend dingue. Ce système est malade,
profondément malade. Donc voilà, on on
moi je me je suis dit il faut sortir de
ce système, parler directement à la
population de ce pays. C'est pas
possible euh que ça continue comme ça à
ce point parce qu'après tous les choix
citoyens qui sont faits dans les urnes
et ailleurs dépendent de ces espèces de
robinet à mauvaise information qui fait
que les gens sont complètement
intoxiquées. Mais c'est hyper dangereux
en fait. C'est hyper dangereux. Moi ça
me ça ça me terrifie. C'est
dangereux. Pourquoi ? Mais c'est
dangereux parce que quand tu as 65
millions de personnes qui euh sont
désinformées euh mais au secours quoi,
les gens ils payent des impôts, ils
votent, on peut faire la guerre après,
on peut faire n'importe quoi, tu vois.
Parce que si on croit n'importe quoi,
enfin c'est euh comment dire, je sais
pas comment dire, je peux pas
t'expliquer un truc évident, ça me rend
fou moi. Donc il faut d'urgence sortir
de ce système pourri, franchement
d'urgence et parler aux citoyens de ce
pays en disant à un moment donné, il va
falloir que vous vous y mettiez parce
que nous on va essayer d'être honnête et
d'être clean mais il faut que vous nous
aidiez. miracle, ça marche. Coup de bol,
ça marche pour vous, ça marche pour nous
un petit peu mais ça marche un peu. Bon
ben là, il y a un truc qui est en train
de se passer, c'est super. Et après, moi
des fois j'en ai marre aussi de bosser
16 heures par jour, d'être mal payé.
Enfin, moi je suis obligé de louer des
bagnoles en autopartage pour bouffer et
nourrir mes mots. Enfin, tu vois, moi je
me paye
rien pendant 2 ans, mais j'avais un peu
de tune canal, ça allait. Puis après
quand j'ai plus rien, je me suis payé
là, je me paye 1500 balles par mois
quoi. Je suis même pas au SMIC depuis 5
ans. Donc comment je fais ? Bah, en
fait, moi je je loue des bagnoles en
autopartage en fait.
Ouais, j'ai acheté des bagnoles sur le
Boncoin à pas cher. Je les lou en
autopartage, ça fait marrer mes potes et
mes collègues. Mais mais oui, mais parce
que comment tu veux que enfin, je veux
dire, moi j'ai encore une barque à
payer. J'ai j'ai bon j'ai trois gamins,
j'en ai un un à charge mais 1500 € par
mois, c'est compliqué quoi. Donc donc
voilà, donc je fais des activités à côté
en fait en même temps que que off
investigation parce que nous on n pas de
milliardaire, on n pas de tune, voilà
quoi. Et donc mais je veux dire des fois
j'en ai un peu marre aussi de passer 16
heures par jour et les weekends et
cetera pour aider à refonder modestement
le système informationnel français. Et
j'envie aussi enfin des fois on me dit
[__] c'est dur ça rentre pas. J'ai
envie de dire aux gens de se payer aussi
mais à un moment donné les citoyens mais
en fait il va falloir prendre votre
destin en main. C'estàd que si vous
soutenez pas les médias indépendants que
nous on essaie de relever ben [__] on
va tous dans le mur quoi. Mais c'est
aussi la responsabilité des citoyens
parce qu'on peut se plaindre de tel ou
tel actionnaire de Macron de Bolloré et
cetera. Bon moi c'est pas mon pote mais
à un moment donné les mecs il profitent
d'un système on les laisse travailler.
Bah ils font ils font ils font ce qu'ils
font hein. Les mecs ils prennent les
médias vas-y c'est bon je vais aider tel
candidat pour qu'il soit président.
Personne m'a vu. Je fais ce que je veux.
comme je m'en fous, il y a pas de règle
machin. OK, on les laisse faire. Je veux
dire, le pouvoir politique laisse faire
ces gens. Donc on va pas taper non plus
sur les industriels indéfiniment. Il y a
un pouvoir politique qui est
complètement couché devant ces gens.
Donc il y a un problème. Et les seuls
qui peuvent sauver ce [__] de pays,
c'est les citoyens franchement. Et ils
sont là, nous on a des messages d'enfer
sur YouTube comme vous, j'imagine, ça
fait plaisir. Ils sont là, ils bosent,
ils donnent de la tune, on y arrive, on
n'est pas très cher, on fait gaffe, on
économise chaque euro, on fait attention
et à mon avis, on est en train de
réussir un truc. Mais après, voilà, si
demain nous on n pas les campagnes de
don qui marchent où les gens s'abonnent
pas, bon ben voilà. Moi à Canal quand
j'ai senti que ça allait s'écrouler,
j'avais passé de 5000 à zéro avec trois
enfants, j'ai passé mon permis VTC en
fait pour être chauffeur de taxi. Bah
oui, bah il faut survivre, tu vois. Donc
passer le permis VTC et après je me suis
aperçu que je pouvais acheter des
bagnoles sur le Boncoin, les mettre en
autopartage. Alors entre les deux
activités, c'est marrant parce que quand
tu crées un MIA indépendant, il y a une
différence, c'est si tu es chauffeur
VTC, en fait, tu es 9h par jour derrière
un volant. Et je me suis dit pendant 2
ans, je vais gérer un métier indépendant
derrière un volant. Bon, c'est quand
même compliqué. Après, je me suis dis
bah non, mais en fait, si je loue des
voitures en autopartage, elle se louent
toute seule avec un boîtier magique et
moi je peux gérer mon médiia. Donc
voilà, mais c'est pour dire que ouais,
on en est tous à faire deux trois
boulots. Les jeunes qui vent chez nous,
on peut pas les payer très bien mais
franchement il tirent le diable par la
queue quoi. Ça me fait de la peine. Et
quand tu vois que la majorité des aides
à la presse, elles vont financer Bernard
Arnaud, j'ai rien contre lui. Mais on se
fout de notre gueule quoi. Mais jusqu'à
quel point on se fout de notre gueule ?
Tout ça pris dans les poches des
Français à qui on ne donne pas leur avis
pour financer 5 milliardaires. Enfin,
Arnaud, il rachète le Parisien, il
renflout en permanence le Parisien qui
chope je sais pas combien de millions
d'euros d'a public. Le journal tombe des
mains des gens qui le lisent plus parce
que de toute façon il est
instrumentalisé. Mais c'est quoi ce
délire ? On se fout de notre gueule
quoi. Grave. Tu
as les sources du fait qu' il soit
instrumentalisé
le Parisien. Ah ben nous on avait fait
une enquête sur la la façon dont les
grands milliardaires de la presse
avaient aidé Macron à monter et on avait
débriefé. Oui. Notamment une personne de
la SDJ du Parisien qui nous racontait
ben l'interview de du patron de la CGT.
Non, elle a été trapée les grèves. Bah
en fait, enfin il fallait protéger
Macron Ellisabeth Borne à tout prix
quand il passe au 493 en force à
l'Assemblée, c'est le gouvernement joue
la sécurité. Enfin, les gens du Parisien
eux-mêmes sont en souffrance depuis des
années de dire "Mais c'est pas possible
de faire des unes aussi favorables à
Macron." En plus, ils écrivent des
papiers puis après la haute à la
direction nommée par un actionnaire qui
retitre, qui fait la une, machin. C'est
de la c'est de l'intox en fait. Et tous
ces journalistes qui bossent dans ces
journaux, moi j' franchement j'aimerais
pas être à leur place quoi. Mais à un
moment donné dans ce métier, soit on
essaie de le faire à peu près bien. Je
dis pas qu'on fait bien, on fait des
conneries, on n'est pas parfait,
personne n'est parfait, mais on essaie
de le faire avec un peu de droiture et
de d'éthique publique. Enfin, pardon,
d'utiliser un gros mot, d'éthique
publique, soit on fait autre chose.
Tu connais la théorie des bayonnettes
intelligentes ?
Non.
Imagine-toi, tu es militaire ou tu es
forces de l'ordre, tu reçois un ordre
qui est contraire à ta profession de la
République.
Bah oui.
Bah tu prends ta bayonnette et tu dis
non.
Ben voilà,
c'est ce que tu as fait.
Bah bien sûr. Moi je enfin comme plein
de gens, j'ai j'ai ça ça m'a pas échappé
qu'un moment donné quand tu es dans un
système où tu es censé obéir à des
ordres, bah ouais, tu obéisir à
désordres tant qu'elles sont à peu près
cohérentes dans l'intérêt général de ta
communauté humaine. Si c'est contre
voilà. Enfin, moi je vais te raconter
une histoire sur un service militaire
parce que j'ai malheureusement été
obligé de d'aller faire le clown dans
l'armée à un moment donné. Quoi
faire le clown ? Tu as été chez le
coiffeur.
Ouais, ça a été compliqué mais je te
résume.
[grognement] Euh moi j'étais étudié en
école journalisme. OK 22 23 ans, je
rentre au CFJ, je suis hyper content et
tout. Là-dessus l'armée, il me font bah
attends faut venir faire ton service là.
Normal.
Les gens n'y savent pas mais voilà. À
l'époque il y avait le service. OK. Je
leur dis bah vous êtes enfin soyez cool
quoi, je suis 2 ans au CF, laissez-moi
finir après je viens. Ah non non, faut
venir tout de suite.
Et donc tu as été fait photographe de
guerre ou tu as été conducteur de char ?
Je t'explique. Ils me disent faut venir
tout de suite sinon euh enfin en gros
non ils me disent alors si tu veux finir
tes études OK mais il faut venir l'été
prochain tu fais une préparation
militaire supérieure pour être officier.
OK je dis OK je joue le jeu. J'y vais
machin préparation militaire supérieure
et cetera. Euh
tu as fait ça où ?
Dans le giurra je crois au Val d'aron.
Donc je prends le fusil, je m'habille en
verre et bon moi je suis pas trop je
suis pas trop militariste mais bon je
joue le jeu tu vois
surtout la coupe militaire avec tes
oreilles ça doit être compliqué porter
de toute façon si les cheveux ils
poussent et tu vois ça fait déjà la
Davis ça monte comme ça donc c'est pas
possible t que au moins ils m'ont coupé
mais attends c'est pas ça bon là ils ont
dû me couper bon bref PMS apprends le
fusil démonter le fusil ça dure 15 jours
et cetera puis bon bref moi ça me
saoulait donc à la fin le mec il me
remet ma médaille puis me dit de façon
toi tu la mérites pas bon bref et mais
ça s'arrête pas là peu importe je joue
jeu je fais la colo des militaires
machin je retourne à l'école de
journalisme [rires]
je finis mon diplôme machin Et après il
me dit bon bah maintenant c'est bon faut
faire les classes là faut aller faire
l'armée puis je me dis oh ça me saoule
et tout ça. Puis j'avais un copain qui
avait grandi sans papa. Il me dit "Mais
c'est important quand même, c'est une
référence paternelle l'armée. Viens, on
va la faire." Je fais "Vas-y, tu as
raison, on va la faire." On va infantter
le blau. Premier jour, ils nous font
attendre 7h dans un couloir pour nous
couper les cheveux. Bon moi j'attends 1h
2h au bout de 2h ça me saoule. Je fais
"Vas-y, 7h attendre ça me saoule." Donc
le lendemain j'arrête de manger. Donc le
chef, il me dit "Non mais tu as pas le
droit de pas manger là."
Tu fait une grève de la fin là ?
Ah ouais
sans déconner. C'était nul hein parce
qu'attends, j'arrive à l'infirmerie, il
y avait des mecs, il montaient sur les
poteaux à minuit, ils prenent les
extincteurs, ils arrosaient les chefs.
Il y en a un autre, il dit "Moi, je vais
me par la fenêtre et tout." Donc moi,
j'arrive à l'infirmerie, les mecs ils me
disent "Tu fais quoi toi ?" Je dis "Bah
moi, j'ai pas envie de rester donc je
mange pas." Ah bruti, ça va jamais
marcher. Tu vas voir, c'est nul,
dans le nez,
c'est nul. [rires]
Bon, bref, donc j'arrête de bouffer.
Enfin bref, parce que
Combien de temps tu as tenu ?
11 jours.
Ça va.
Tu as perdu combien de kilos ?
Ça va 10.
C'est pour dire,
tu es très musclé
en fait. Ouais. Je suis toujours Non
enfit [rires]
non mais en fait l'armée si tu veux le
premier jour c'est 7h pour te couper les
cheveux et le soir ils nous disent alors
au milieu de la nuit on va siffler vous
êtes 25 dans la chambre vous devez tous
descendre les 9u étages en courant dans
la cour le mec qui arrive en dernier il
fait punir toute la chambré c'est
compris les mecs et tout le monde fait
oui oui chef et moi je me dis attends
ils vont nous réveiller au milieu de la
nuit il faut courir en marchant sur les
copains en mettant ses rangers et il y
aura toujours un mec qui sera dernier en
fait il va être puni.
peut-être bien l'armée. Moi ça me gonfle
en fait. Donc
c'est vrai que on a bien l'armée, on
respecte l'armée.
On respecte l'armée. Bon en tout cas moi
je suis un peu plus anarchiste, ça me
saoule. Donc je me dis [__] faut
courir à Claire Josh. Le dernier va
faire punir tout le monde. J'ai le
sentiment de rentrer dans une espèce de
de nous matrixer un peu la tête, ça me
gonfle. Donc je dis j'ai plus faim. Bon
et là les chefs, ils me disent non mais
attends faut manger. C'est obligatoire.
Donc petite foulée, tout le monde part
en réfectoire. Moi je me fous en
dernier. Je fais ben j'ai pas faim, j'ai
tu vas manger. OK donc j'y vais. Donne
un plateau. Je fais OK je mange pas quoi
tu as intérêt à manger. Non mais j'ai
pas faim. Je peux rien toi. J'ai pas
faim. C'est d'ailleurs 5 jours, je me
dis dans 5 jours, je vais tomber dans
les pommes, ils vont me lâcher la
grappe. Tu vois, en fait, c'est chiant
hein parce que 3 jours, tu as la tête
qui tourne mais en fait 4 jours, tu es
toujours là quoi. Alors bon et puis ils
me disent bon bah tu vas aller là. Le le
colonel me convoque et puis il me dit
ben euh tu fais exprès donc on va
t'envoyer au tribunal. Là je fais ah oh
chef pas du tout j'ai la tête qui
tourne. Bonok infirmerie machin. Et
là-bas c'est de toute façon si tu manges
pas dans 3 semaines on te met sous
perfusion pas très sympa tu vois. Puis
après le mec il change de ton le
lendemain. Mais tu veux une pomme ? Non,
j'ai pas de pommes, mais ça 11 jours et
à la fin, je vois toutes les mecs de
l'infirmerie qui partent chez chez le
psychiatre pour être réformé. Donc sur
800 mecs de la caserne, il y en a 12 qui
voulaient pas y aller. Donc ils en envoi
11 à l'infirmerie. Je dis pourquoi moi
je je vais pas voir le psychiatre, ça
fait quand même 11 jours j'ai un peu
faim, enfin j'en ai marre quoi. Non, toi
tu vas pas. Donc je leur dis bah si vous
me si vous m'envoyez pas chez une
infirmerie, je me je me je m'ouvre les
veines. En fait, c'est pas dans ce
sens-là. Mais bon, il faut pas il faut
pas il faut pas faire ça. Je
jamais fait hein. Et je leur dis si vous
me laissez pas y aller, je m'ouvre les
veines. Et je savais pas mais en fait à
l'époque si tu menaçais de te suicider,
ça les flipper. Donc il disait bah ok
donc le mec me dit attendez je vais voir
le chef. Il remonte il fait bon c'est
bon demain vous allez voir le
psychiatre. Bref psychiatre et cetera et
après en ressortant de chez le
psychiatre tout le monde était parano
dans le camion. Tout le monde continua à
faire le golio de première et cetera
parce qu'on avait peur qu'il nous
dénonce machin. Enfin bref. Non, mais
tout ça pour dire que moi j'aime pas
trop qu'on m'oblige à faire des choses
quoi, tu vois. J'ai besoin de me sentir
éthiquement dans un truc correct
et libre
et libre. Donc voilà. Donc quand Boré il
arrive en 2015, ça met une pression à
Canal mais euh je m'en fous moi, tu
vois, je dis vas-y, tu veux me forcer à
censurer une enquête ? Vas-y, mon pote,
on va se mar J'ai fait au jour de gr de
la fin,
il y a un bon resto à canal
d'entreprise, on va tenir 5 ans, c'est
bon. Bref, non mais c'est pour dire que
dans dans le métier qu'on fait,
franchement si on peut essayer de enfin
on a une responsabilité par rapport aux
gens, on fait un métier public, on gagne
un peu de tune, on a notre gueule machin
et cetera. Enfin, pas toi mais beaucoup.
Vas-y. En plus, tu vas faire des
ménages, faire n'importe quoi et dire
"Bah, je peux pas, faut que je paye mon
loyer." Bah attends, merde quoi. Ça va
quoi. Et c'est pour ça que les gens
perdent confiance dans les journalistes.
On peut pas faire ce métier. On fait pas
n'importe quel métier, merde quoi. On
faut le faire avec un
le 4e pouvoir.
Bah ouais, normalement quoi. Enfin, si
on veut être le 4e pouvoir, faut être un
peu digne quoi. C'est pas voilà. Donc un
peu de un peu gaffe à ce qu'on fait
quoi. C'est un peu normal. Après, je dis
pas qu'on est parfait hein, on peut
faire des conneries mais on essaie quoi.
Et le côté, j'y peux rien. Mon
actionnaire, il a dit non. De petit
renoncement, petit renoncement. B c'est
pas possible quoi. Moi enfin moi je suis
très très sceptique aujourd'hui sur les
propriétés des médias qui appartiennent
à des grosses boîtes ou à l'état. Je
crois que c'est compliqué quoi.
Philanthropie
et les gens ils ont compris en France
hein. Les gens ils soutiennent les
médias dés maintenant.
Donc un un autre documentaire qui a
cartonné sur votre plateforme
un témoignage un témoignage d'un mec et
puis le mec a disparu il y a pas
longtemps. Là c'était quelle affaire
déjà ?
Euh qui c'est qui a disparu ? Ah oui tu
parles pas d'un certain Olivier Marlex ?
Non pas Olivier.
Ah, tu es horrible toi. Vas-y, parle
d'Olivier.
Non, rien. On avait fait dans la
première saison un documentaire sur
l'affaire Alstom. Donc ce ce fleuron de
la de la de l'industrie française.
Voilà, dont la branche énergie avait été
bradée aux Américains de général
électrique notamment avec Montebourg et
Macron. Mais pas mal Macron qui dès son
arrivée en 2012,
voilà, dès 2012 allisé très secrètement,
il demande un rapport sur tiens, est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas machin ? Bon bref,
donc ils vont brader à Stom aux
Américains avec des cabinets d'avocats
d'affaires au milieu qui s'en mettent
plein les fouilles pendant des mois. euh
et une perte de souveraineté française
importante. Tu connais l'histoire.
Voilà. Et du coup euh Marlex avait fait
Ouais, une commission d'enquête assez
assez sérieuse là-dessus quoi. Et donc
et donc Marlex en fait, on l'avait fait
parler dans ce doc sur et après on a
refait ce qu'on appelle nous un off
interview. On a repris son interview de
l'époque, on l'a remis en 30 ou 40
minutes en le laissant parler. Marlex,
pas juste trois phrases dans un doc et
puis ça fait 500000 vues. Ça intéresse
les gens.
La faire Boulin.
Ouais, la faire Boulin. La faire Boulin
ministre
la faire Boulin. Voilà. ministre de
travail de Valérie Giscardestin gauliste
en 79 va se retrouver un peu coincé
entre les les jeunes loups de la Chiraki
du RPR Jacques Chirac Charles Pasquais
qui veulent absolument prendre le
pouvoir dans le mouvement gauliste et
arriver à l'Élysée en 81 et de l'autre
côté Giscar qui veut être réélu. Que
fait Giscar ? Il prend dans ce
gouvernement bar un ministre du travail
égoiste historique respecté qui
s'appelle Robert Boulin. Il le met dans
son écurie. Ça ça divise un peu les
golistes et il joue à faire chez Chiak
en disant de toute façon le Boulin il
est tellement bien, je vais le mettre à
Matignan à 1 an de la présidentielle. Et
là les goistes commencent à flipper
parce qu'ils se disent Boulin il est
respecté euh il est légitime c'est un
vrai gauliste. Pas comme Chiraak hein,
c'est là donc s'il va à Matignon bah là
on fracture la famille gauliste et c'est
ses Giscar qui repassent. Voilà en gros
comment on peut résumer l'histoire. Et
donc les Chirak et Pasquais sont
furieux. Parce quoi ? C'est un sacré
voyou à l'époque. Ils vont commencer à
multiplier les boules puantes contre les
Giscardiens. On est à un an de la
présidentielle. Donc ils vont sortir une
affaire de maison pour Raymon dans le
sud qui poserait problème. Ils vont
sortir les diamants de Bassin pour
Giscar qui est une vraie histoire qui va
plomber Giscar et tout ça c'est en 3
semaines. Et Boulin il a acheté un
terrain ramatuel dans des conditions pas
très claires. On est dans une campagne
d'égolistes pour discréditer faire
tomber la giscardie. Il peut se
comprendre. Boulin va être pris
là-dedans. Sauf que Boulin il va
résister. il va dire "C'est pas vrai,
c'est des conneries. Ça fait 15 ans que
je suis dans les ministères, y compris
aux finances. J'ai été géré un contrat
en Iran. Je sais qu'il s'en met plein
les fouilles. J'ai des dossiers, ça va
chauffer quoi. Je résume. Après, on a
fait un 1h40 mais enfin 1h15 mais j'ai
des dossiers, ça va chauffer sur
YouTube.
Ouais, sur YouTube disponible avec c
libre euh à faire Boulin la piste
Chirac. Euh et donc tout ça pour dire
que Boulin en gros se laisse pas
impressionner par les mauvais coups de
de la bande à Basquis pour faire cours
parce que c'est les mecs du RPR qui
viennent ambiancer les journalistes
Philippe Alexandre et compagnie pour
dire non mais boulin c'est des boules
puantes machin machin machin boulin il
dit non non moi je joue pas comme ça et
si vous continuez je balance les
dossiers d'accord et dans ce contexte
extrêmement tendu il y a énormément
d'indices super suspects qui montrent
que ça chauffe il y a sa famille apprend
par un voisin qui arrive des États-Unis
qu'il y a un contrat sur la tête de
Boulin. le le beau frère de Boulin, donc
le le frère de sa femme Colette dans le
sud-ouest, lui dit "Putain, il y a un
mec de de l'intérieur là, je sais pas
quoi, qui est venu me voir en disant il
y a un contrat, c'est pendant 3 jours."
Enfin, il y a plein d'alères qui
arrivent. Lui, il dit à sa femme "Je
sais, ils veulent me tuer. C'est quand
même gratiné, on est à 3 jours de sa
mort." Et un jour il part de son
ministère à 15h, il prend tous ses
dossiers secrets, il prend sa voiture,
il répudie son chauffeur, il va à Neï et
il prend la route de Monfort Laam tout
seul sans dire où il va. Et c'est
terrible parce que c'est un mystère
historique dingue. On sait pas où il va,
on sait pas ce qu'il fait. On sait qu'il
part vers 16h à Montfort Laamie, qu'à
18h il sera aperçu dans une voiture à
Monfort avec deux types patibulaires qui
l'ont viré de son volant. Il est à
droite sur chez passager. Il a peur et
il y a un mec qui conduit l'autre qui
est derrière. 1 heure après 19h la
famille à nuit prend un coup de fil.
Robert est mort. Robert est mort.
Mystère. Toute la nuit on va le
chercher. Le lendemain matin on va le
trouver dans un étan. Ah le pauvre il
s'est il s'est suicide. Un
gros rouvre.
Ouais à deux pas de gros rouvre. Ouais.
Étant de près des étants de Hollande, ça
s'appelle l'étant rompu sur la commune
de Saint-Léger en Yveline. Deux pas de
gros rouvement fort la morie. Moi, j'ai
passé toute mon enfance là-bas comme
gamin. Mais donc on le retrouve son
corps dans un étant lendemain matin.
Version officielle, il s'est suicidé.
Alors c'est là que ça devient lunaire.
Tous les journaux, la télé Daniel Brem
sur la télévision publique, tout le
monde balance le truc officiel, il s'est
suicidé. Alors que tous les gens qui
interviennent sur le lieu de de la scène
disent "Mais attends, c'est c'est
lunaire en fait. Il est bourré de coup.
Enfin, ça colle pas du tout du tout du
tout." Rigidité cadavérique, pas dans le
bon sens.
Ouais, c'est ça. On le retrouve sur le
ventre alors qu'il a des rigidités
cadavériques dans le dos. Ce qui prouve
que le corps a été entreposé après la
mort au moins plusieurs heures sur le
dos. Donc rien ne colle, mais vraiment
rien ne colle. N'importe quel mec 2 ans
de de police scientifique te démontre
que c'est pas un suicide. Et alors ce
qui est fou c'est qu'à l'époque la
police et la j alors la justice le
procureur de Versailles qui était un peu
une barbouse et cetera tuemballe le truc
terminé celui-ci tout le monde sautait.
et la famille est un peu tétanisée. Elle
va mettre 2 ans à découvrir que dans les
photos du cadavre, mais c'est pas
possible, elle va porter plaintemps 83
et cetera. Et elle se bat depuis 45 ans
pour dire "Attends, on a tué un ministre
en exercice." Ce qui est extrêmement
Ouais. Et en 2015, finalement, la
justice qui est très lente et qui pose
pas toujours très bien, je suis désolé
pour les gens de la justice, finira par
dire "Bah, on réouvre pour enlèvement et
séquestration, assassinat, je sais pas
quoi en 2015." Mais je veux dire, ça
fait 45 ans qu'on a tué un ministre en
exercice dans un complot politique et
que la moitié des gens se ferment les
yeux, qu'on veut rien faire, que la
justice glande, que la presse fait dodo.
Il y a il y a un témoin de l'affaire qui
a dit bon, il était pas censé le tuer,
ils étaient juste en train de
l'impressionner. Il ils l'ont secoué un
peu trop fort. C'est ça.
Ouais. Alors, je me je me méfie un peu
de ce que peuvent dire tous les témoins
parce que nous, on n'est pas la justice.
Je je viens de critiquer la justice,
mais je veux dire en même temps nous
journalistes, on n'est pas la justice.
Donc moi, je vais pas me substituer au
juge, on est juste journaliste, on fait
ce qu'on peut modestement puis moi, j'ai
pas non plus les moyens d'enquête de la
justice et cetera. Donc c'est la justice
de faire le boulot. Mais ça fait quand
même 25 ans qu'un certain nombre de
témoins proches alors déjà première truc
de fou dans les mois qui suivent la mort
de Robert Boulin en octobre 79 il y a
neuf personnes qui vont soit être très
sérieusement menacé soit mourir de mort
violente. Ces gens sont tous des gens
qui sont proches de Boulin proches de
l'affaire qui savaient des choses, qui
avaient des confidences. Mais c'est
lunaire, on le raconte à la fin de notre
doc, on a un retrouvé mort sur une
autoroute alors qu'il y avait pas de
raison. L'autre il s'écrase dans un
avion au Cameroun, l'autre machin, enfin
tu serais complotiste, tu serais content
quoi. Mais c'est factuel, il y a neuf
morts et Colette Boulin, donc la femme
menacé euh si vous portez plainte, votre
fils va subir le même sourire que votre
père par un gauliste Hil Peretti, patron
le maire de Neïi. Enfin, c'est c'est
vraiment c'est une mafia gauliste qui
est en train de leur dire vous fermez
vos gueules, personne porte plainte
quoi. Non, mais il est toujours vivant
ce monsieur ?
Non, il est mort chez Peretti. Euh quand
il a pris rendez-vous, tu racontes quand
il a pris rendez-vous avec l'épouse ou
de mois après la mort pour dire arrêtez
de faire chier, colette, ça suffit
surtout portez pas plainte et cetera.
C'est un baron d'une RPR de l'époque. La
famille sait tellement bien qu'elle va
être subir des pressions qu'elle met un
petit magnétophone sur le sur le
l'armoire. D'accord. Donc mais c'est
lunaire hein, ils enregistrent la visite
d'Achil Peretti chez Colette Boulin à
Neuï. Il va la menacer. Il dit "Écoutez,
on vous donne ce que vous voulez, des
milliards mais taisez-vous, portez pas
plain." C'est ce que raconte longuement
sa fille que Fabienne Boulin qui était
témoin du rendez-vous. Je dis "Mais
c'est dingue, vous avez enregistré le
truc avec Peretti, c'est quand même
c'est une des très nombreuses pièces qui
montre qu'il y a un complot dans cette
affaire." Elle dit oui mais la cassette
on l'a filé à un Jean S2 TF1 qui donc en
83 je crois donc quelques années après
va sortir cet enregistrement d'Achil
Perity dans un sujet de TF1 au journal
télévisé. Je me dis bon ben génial tu as
plus la cassette mais je vais aller à
Lina je vais retrouver. Tu vas à Lina tu
retrouves plus le sujet tu retrouves
plus le sujet du JT où il y avait cet
extrait. Alors c'est pas forcément un
complot. Peut-être qu'à Lina en 83 les
mecs il rangent pas très bien les JT.
Moi, j'ai cru comprendre que c'était
plus ou moins bien rangé. Des fois tu
avais des JT qui étaient pas et cetera.
Je veux pas tirer les conséquences
excessives mais nous on n' jamais remis
la main sur cet enregistrement. NZ pas
non plus Bonois Colomba qui est le pape
de ce sujet qui bose depuis 20 ans. Donc
bon enfin il y a énormément d'éléments
qui montrent que le RPR était très
tendu. Il y a 7 ou h morts autour de
Boulin et tous ceux qui ont bossé dessus
ont eu des menaces. Et 20 ans après,
donc en 2002, il y a l'ancien suppléant
de Boulin Libourne qui dit "Putain, à
l'époque j'avais fouillé un peu dans ces
archives, j'avais trouvé tout ce qu'il
avait trouvé sur Chirak et les
corruptions du RPR et cetera." Il
raconte ça à France Inter à Colomba
quelques jours ou semaines après. Il est
dans sa baraque en région avec sa femme
le soir un dîner avec des amis. Des mecs
sont venus le chercher dans son bar
l'après-midi en cherchant où il était.
On est des anciens copains de classe,
c'est sympa. Il est où ? On voudrait le
voir. Bon bizarre. Le soir il sort de sa
baraque, il va chercher une bouteille de
pinard dans sa cave. Donc dans la nuit
il sort. Euh deux types devant chez lui
vont le taper à coup de batte de
baseball, le laisser pour mort avec le
crâne à moitié défoncé euh et s'enfuir
parce qu'il avait parlé à France inter
20 ans après la mère de Boulin en disant
qu'il avait eu les archives de Boulin.
Donc ça veut dire que 20 ans après, tu
as encore des réseaux proche du sac ou
de la droite dure des pascoyens qui
disent au moindre témoin, tu parles, je
te je te tue quoi. Donc il va survivre
ce type, il va survivre et puis il est
mort il est mort récemment mais ça nous
a frappé. Et dans ce contexte, 40 ans
après la mort de Boulin, on apprend
qu'un ancien truant Eliot d'Armont en
Bretagne euh commence à parler à la
justice depuis 2 ou 3 ans. Il a euh vidé
son sac. Il a dit "Ben moi, j'ai assisté
quelques jours après la mort du ministre
dans un club de échangistes de ville
d'Avr à une discussion de responsable du
sac qui évoque la mort du ministre."
Bon, il balance tout à la justice. Ça a
l'air intéressant. Je sais pas si c'est
vrai. Moi, je suis pas juge, c'est juste
un mec qui dit ça. OK. Mais c'est
lunaire, je veux dire. On apprend qu'il
parle. Il parle à France 2 en août 2025
dans une interview. C'est la première
fois qu'il parle au médias après avoir
parlé à la juge le 12 août 2025 un truc
comme ça. Et le 29 août, on apprend par
l'association Robert Boulin qui suite
affaire et qui sait de faire la vérité
que le mec a été visé par des tirs par
balle à son domicile de Bretagne en
pleine nuit. Il a entendu du bruit,
c'est un vieux, il vit seul, son chien
fait du bruit, il sort dehors, il va
voir, il entend rien, il tourne les
talons, il se prend deux balles qui se
viennent se ficher dans sa dans sa
baraque. Bon, donc quelqu'un a tiré sur
ce témoin 40 ans après. Moi, je trouve
ça lunaire. Je me dis mais ils vont le
finir. Donc je me je me jette dans une
dans un train, je me prpite là-bas pour
recueillir l'interview de ce mec avant
qu'il meur. On fait 2 heures d'interview
et puis on se dit bah faut en faire
quelque chose quoi. Bon et puis après il
est mort là récemment. Il était retrouvé
décédé dans son domicile il y a il y a
quelques jours
de mort naturelle.
Je sais pas, il était assez âgé, il
avait un respirateur, il est peut-être
mort de mort naturelle. Je sais que le
le la gendarmerie faisait une enquête
sur sa mort.
Oui, c'est la question que j'ai posé. La
gendarmerie, il y a eu une expertise
balistique, les gens sont venus pour
sortir les balles, il y a eu quelque
chose
?
Donc le les tirs ont lieu vers 1h du
matin dans la nuit du
quel calibre.
Alors apparemment lui ce qu'il dit et ce
que le gendarme aurait constaté c'est
qu'on retrouve des cartouches debout sur
la route. Donc pour te résumer donc vers
1h du matin, il sort le chien fait du
bruit, il va voir il entend rien. Son
chien fil dans le noir, il sait pas ce
qui se passe.
C'est quoi comme chien ?
Espèce de berger allemand.
Très bien.
Il il va il revient sur ses pas, ça
tire, il flippe, ça lui pète le four qui
est sur sa terrasse, je sais pas quoi et
cetera. Bon, il rentre chez lui, il
appelle les gendarmes, les gendarmes
arrivent et il trouvent des pas des
douilles apparemment des cartouches, je
pense que des cartouches de chasse posé
debout comme ça. Bon, lui c'est un
ancien truant du milieu, c'est un mec un
peu particulier. Il dit "Bon, ça je vois
ce que ça veut dire. C'est un
avertissement, ces gens on peut
revenir." Les gendarmes le lisent
également un peu de la même façon et le
lendemain, il porte plainte pour
tentative d'assassinat. Mais il dit,
"Les gendarmes, ils m'ont dit "Mais
peut-être vous qui avez organisé ce truc
là, ils sont un peu sceptiques, ils
savent pas très bien. Bon, normal, les
gendarmes ils bossent, on voit ce qu'ils
font, ils font leur boulot, tu vois.
Mais ça débouche sur rien. Et quelques
jours après, il dit quand même enfin
vous voyez pour enfin les gendarmes lui
disent à votre avis pourquoi on vous
tire dessus ? Il dit bah vous savez ce
que je raconte à justice sur Boulin. Oui
oui on voit. D'accord. OK. Bon donc il
jour après, il demande un permis de por
d'arme. Pourquoi ? Juste chez lui
d'avoir une un flingue chez lui parce
qu'il dit "Mais moi, je suis tout seul
dans ma baraque isolée au bord de ma
voie de chemin de fer un peu flippant la
nuit. Les mecs peuvent revenir quand
même." Et euh son avocate demande
désespérément un permis de por. Elle ne
l'obtient pas. Donc ses copains
Manouches du CR d'à côté finissent par
lui amener un gun quoi qui planque sous
son lit et puis et puis il attend quoi.
Et donc bon moi je fais son interview,
on retourne le voir 8 jours après. On
espère qu'il va pas se faire tuer. Bon
et puis surtout lui il dit mais il faut
que je sois entendu par la justice
encore une fois. J'ai d'autres trucs à
dire. La justice tarde énormément à
entendre les témoins dans cette affaire.
Donc il meurent les uns après les
autres. Ça fait 40 ans. C'est quand même
chelou ce que tu me dis. C'estàdire que
tu as un ancien truyon qui reçoit deux
bastos chez lui, il va juste voir ses
copains manouches pour prendre un 9 mm
ou un truc comme ça.
Mais parce que les autorités le
protègent pas.
D'accord. Mais tu vas au BHV du coin,
moi il m'arrive un truc comme ça. Tu
rentres, tu rentres chez moi, tu
ressors, c'est le Pakistan,
c'est-à-dire tu te tu vas t'armer.
Non, je vais pas m'armer, je vais piéger
la baraque.
Mais alors, c'est
je vais pas la piéger. Je vais pas la
piéger avec de la poutte de parle
pimpinin
mais c'est ce qu'il nous dit. Attends,
moi, je me jette là-bas.
Je vais mettre des pieds jaloux. Euh je
vais mettre des extincteurs remplis avec
d'autres choses que de la poudre.
Bien sûr. Attends moi, j'y vais 48 he
après les tirs. D'accord. Je je le vois
toute une soirée, je recueille son
interview et il ressort dehors, il me
montre où ça s'est passé, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et cetera et il me dit de
toute façon moi euh moi j'ai dit au
gendarme hein, moi je vais pas rester
comme ça. Je vais prendre un gun et la
prochaine fois qu'ils arrivent, je les
tue pas forcément et je leur tire dans
les jambes. Et il dit les gendarmes
m'ont dit "Bah oui, vous avez raison,
vous êtes en usine de défense, on vous
comprend." Enfin bon, c'est un peu
lunaire comme réponse. Un mec, un témoin
clé d'une affaire d'État avec la meurtre
un ministre, faut pas le tuer, il faut
le prendre vivant.
Mais peut-être, mais en tout cas, non,
il faut prendre vivant le gars qui
rentre chez toi. Ser rien de débuter
parce que ou mais le gars, il est venu
il y a de jours, il est parti. Donc si
tu lui il dit "Ouais, mais s'il revient,
tu chopes, tu le ligotes,
c'est ce qu'il dit.
Tu attends une petite demi-heure
histoire de le faire causer,
tu le mets sur une petite goutte, sais,
il y a une petite goutte qui tombe, ça
fait pit pchit à chaque fois toutes les
2 minutes. Puis ensuite, tu appelles la
gendarmerie, il est tombé dans mon bon
dans mon bordel. Il s'est un peu brûlé
la tête.
Tu aurais dû faire Hod d'Armon. Et en
tout cas, d'ormand, moi ce qu'il me dit
c'est je je vais prendre un gun et je
vais tirer sur le mec s'il revient. Et
c'est il dit ça au gendarme comme une
boutade genre mais protégez-moi, je vais
faire un malheur. Et mec lui dis non non
mais pas de problème, on comprend, on
prend un gun. Tu vois enfin c'est c'est
bon, c'est quand même un peu spécial.
La violence c'est pas bien. Euh il faut
faire confiance au for de l'ordre.
Ses potes, il me raconte ses potes les
manouches lui amènent une arme
clandestinement parce qu'il a pas son
permis de porme mais il prend quand même
une arme. Après je le comprends, le mec
il se fait tirer dessus. Moi ça m'aurait
pas fait marrer. Je suis comme toi. Bon,
il prend une arme, il attend, il se
passe rien. Il attend une semaine, 10
jours, 15 jours. Euh, il se passe rien.
Et euh
mais mais enfin,
je sais pas. Certes, c'est 40 ans après,
plein de gens me disent "Mais enfin,
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire ?
Pourquoi les golistes dont Pascois est
mort déjà depuis 10 ans voudrait encore
faire terre un témoin, c'est n'importe
quoi et tout Peut-être, je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé avec Hud d'Armon, je le
connais pas plus que ça. Bon, mais en
tout cas, quand on regarde sur les 40
années, il y a 8 9 10 personnes qui ont
été encore une fois soit mort violente,
soit très lourdement menacé. Euh voilà.
Et par ailleurs, les gens qui essayent
de discréditer Boulin de l'affaiblir, de
le faire tomber avant sa mort, c'est
Charles Pasquis qui envoie des
émissaires euh des fois qui va en
personne au siège du monde donné à euh
James Sarasin, je rése du monde un
dossier sur un verboulin en disant vous
allez voir ça pue la faire normelle.
Pasqua en personne, il est le bras droit
de Chirc à l'époque. Faut savoir que
Boulin avait repéré que Pasquais avait
magouillé des élections internes au RPR
à l'été 79. Boulin l'avait dénoncé au
parti. Pasquais avait été viré des
instances dirigeantes du RPA. Donc il y
avait eu un clash Pascois Boulin. Boulin
avait dénoncé Pasqua comme un truandeur
d'élection. Pascois avait été viré des
instances dirigeantes du RPR et dans la
foulée, il balance des boules puantes
contre Boulin. Une bagarre lunaire. Et
donc Pasqua, ancien dirigeant du sac
aurait eu un rôle important dans le dans
un espèce de complot contre.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Réel, tu fais
attention, il va resserrer sa caméra
parce qu'il a pas bien équilibré sur le
plan serré. Donc tu te mets sur le plan
large. OK. Toi, tu fais gaffe parce que
la caméra va basculer en avant quand tu
vas desserrer. Voilà.
Tiens, tu te mets la main en dessous.
Pardon, excusez-moi pour ce détail. B,
tu connais, c'est la
Je je peux all faire pipi. Non, je
non, il y a que moi qui a le droit de
faire ça aussi. continue ton histoire de
Boulin.
Bon, enfin bref, donc
je peux pas tout détailler, on a fait un
docart sur Boulin, mais Pascois a probé
un rôle très important dans un complot
politique contre Boulin qui a été dans
un rendez-vous mystérieux à Monfamori en
octobre 79 qui vient tomber sur on sait
pas qui, le sac, le service d'action
civique, la milice gauliste est pas très
loin. Euh il aurait été enlevé cogné
d'après Lionarmont euh battu à mort.
Alors, ils ont battu un peu trop fort,
ils ont pas fait exprès ou ils voulaient
faire exprès. Je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais cet homme a été battu et
probablement battu à mort. Et on a pris
son corps, on l'a mis dans un étan dans
la nuit et on a voulu faire croire qu'il
s'était suicidé. et la machine d'état
française de l'époque a martelé qui
s'était suicidé et a réussi à imposer
cette thèse. Et les h ou neuf personnes
qui pouvaient éventuellement démentir
cette thèse dans les mois qu'on suivi
sont à peu près tous morts. Donc euh
voilà, [raclement de gorge] je je moi je
je crois pas beaucoup au complot, quoi.
Qu'encore ça puisse arriver, je suis pas
complotiste, mais il y a un moment
donné, il y a quand même un [__] de
sujet. Et encore une fois, moi je juste
un petit journaliste comme d'autres
petits journalistes Fabienne Bouan, elle
dit "C'est la chaîne processionnaire,
vous êtes plusieurs journalistes à avoir
fait le boulot de manière incroyable
depuis 40 ans, mais vous êtes
quelques-uns dans un océan où vous
faites un peu avancer et la justice
essaie aussi un peu de faire avancer."
Mais moi ce que je me dis c'est dans une
affaire pareille, comment c'est possible
qu'un pays comme la France soit pas
capable de dire "On veut savoir comment
est mort un ministre en exercice." C'est
quand même un mec du gouvernement. Ou
alors si on peut tuer notre gouvernement
sans qu'on bouge, mais on est qui en
fait ? Enfin, il y a un problème. Donc
la justice marche pas, elle va nous dire
"J'ai pas de moyen." OK, je sais, c'est
pas la faute des justes, ils ont pas de
moyens, mais qu'est-ce que ce pouvoir
politique est pas capable depuis 79 de
faire la lumière sur un marque
politique, quoi. Enfin, moi ça me
choque, ça ça m' cœur, quoi.
Est-ce que tu as regardé la commission
sur l'audiovisuel public ?
Un petit peu,
un petit peu. On a on a mis deux trois
jeunes journalistes chez nous sur le sur
les sur les auditions. Alors, il y en
avait beaucoup beaucoup donc, il y avait
beaucoup de taf. Enfin, on a pris les de
tiers des auditions, on se les fadé et
on a fait un petit un petit bestof un
peu des auditions de la de la commission
audios public. Euh et ta question c'est
quel regard on porte ? Alors pour faire
court parce que c'est très difficile de
résumer 6 mois de boulot de Alonc et
compagnie mais pour faire cours nous on
a eu le sentiment que Alon allait
vraiment essayer de chercher un peu
obsessionnellement des gauchistes à
France télé.
[grognement]
Euh,
attends, je te coupe.
Tu as pas l'impression qu'il y a
beaucoup de gauchistes chez les
journalistes et que tous les médias en
fait, ils sont de gauche et quand tu es
de droite, bah tu te fais laté par tes
collègues.
Est-ce que tu as pas l'impression que
c'est une chasse gardée d'une certaine
gauche ?
Alors,
j'en profite parce que toi tu es à
l'archa ou
Ouais, ouais, juste gauche. Ouais.
Euh,
si tu veux, enfin je pardon, je vais
rester 2 secondes sur un truc précis. Il
cherche des gauchistes à France télé.
Peut-être il y en a. Enfin moi quand je
regarde France Télé, je vois pas que des
gauchistes. Je vois des gens plutôt
plutôt centre gauche proche du PS plutôt
la gauche du gouvernement tu vois. Je
vois des centristes, il y a aussi
quelques mecs de droite et je vois
surtout un autre Josel public un peu
trop inféodé au pouvoir. Alors là, c'est
Macron. Avant c'était Hollande donc oui,
ils sont inféodés à ce pouvoir, on va
dire quoi ? Centre gauche, enfin Macron
de droite, je sais pas ce qu'on peut
dire. Enfin, nous la lecture qu'on a,
c'est que ce ce public est trop
dépendant du pouvoir politique, beaucoup
trop dépendant quoi qu'on en dise, de
l'arcom, de l'indépendance. On a
l'indépendance au bout d'élèves toute la
journée. C'est juste en fait. On n'est
pas indépendant, on est payé par le
enfin financé par le gouvernement. Faut
aller demander un budget. Il y a même
plus la redevance euh sanctuarisée qui
permettait de dire non mais c'est bon,
on a notre financement. Non, c'est
Macron, il a tout tout supprimé.
Maintenant, c'est c'est le l'État qui
décide combien il donne. Donc, faut
aller demander un budget. Enfin bon,
c'est lunaire. Donc, ça c'est un
problème majeur. Lui, moi ma perception
c'est subjectif. Lui, il a été cherché
des gauchises parce qu'il est très à
droite, il va chercher des gauchises.
Bon, certes, il y en a, mais pour moi,
c'est pas tellement le problème. C'est
plutôt que par exemple la quasi totalité
des talkks show politiques de République
de France 5 sont tenus par deux ou trois
producteurs qui fricotent en permanence
avec Macron. C'est quand même un
problème Xavier Niel et cetera. Bon,
c'est des copains, ils ont le droit de
faire de boire des bières.
Ouais mais pourquoi je paye moi ?
Non mais toi pourquoi je paye la TVA ?
Moi je paye pas la TVA pour que Niel
fasse des talk show politiques qui vont
faire plaisir à Macron ou qui
c'est pas Niel qui fait des talk show
politiqu
c'est Mediawan ou que Niel puisse aller
se se vautrer sur le plateau de C'est à
vous pour faire la promotion de sa
nouvelle box. C'est à vous l'émission
qu'il produit. Il va faire la pub de sa
boxe intervé par sa salariée analisabeth
le moine sur France Télévision payé par
ma TVA. Je veux dire, c'est un peu
lunaire. Non non mais ça va quoi. Donc
c'est un peu énervant. Donc quelque part
je trouve que le fait de questionner cet
audiovisel publique de manière majeure
c'était nécessaire et nous ça fait 10
ans, on va faire chier Airnut et les
gens de Radio France qui nous traitent
mais comme des sousmerdes. Des
sousmerdes c'est-à-dire que pas un
instant ils répondent à un mail. Enfin
en tout cas pendant les cin premières
années, ils ont jamais répondu à un
mail. Tu peux jamais leur parler. Je
parle pas d'eux. C'est des gens
importants. Nous on est des des des des
oosau mais
faut jamais tomber dans le misérabisme
l'impuissance.
Non mais qui nous mettent un chargé de
com. Tu vois on est un petit média. Je
veux dire évidemment on a pas le temps
de nous parler, je comprends mais un
chargé de com mais nous quelqu'un on a
une question précise à poser à ta
gestion jamais ces gens ne répondent à
personne. Et comme comme disait le les
gens du parlement, il y a même pas eu de
commission d'enquête sur France Tévision
depuis 10 ans. Donc les journalistes, on
leur répond pas. Élise Luel peut pas
faire des enquêtes sur France Télé,
évidemment, c'est son employeur et et
l'Assemblée ne fait pas le job. Bon donc
il y a un moment donné moi au bout d'un
moment ça m'énerve. Donc oui, bah qui a
une commission, je trouve ça plutôt
assez sain quoi. Après [grognement] euh
je je pense quand même que que Charles
Loncle a été sur extirper les gauchistes
de France Télé. Je pense que le prême
structurel il est pas là. Et et puis là,
tu vois, il y avait l'extrême br dit
faut privatiser le public et à l'on non,
faut juste réduire d'un d'un quart le
financement, pas privatiser. Bon, c'est
pas très mal ce qu'ils veulent mais pour
moi c'est pas le problème fondamental
parce que la vraie question c'est est-ce
qu'il faut que l'État contrôle des
médias ? Enfin, je vais être un peu
cach. Est-ce qu'il faut que l'État
contrôle des médias ? C'est quand même
une vraie question parce que le problème
c'est que euh
ils sont tellement féodés au
gouvernement que demain c'est un autre
gouvernement et ben ils vont nommer des
cadres qui leur vont bien et puis France
Télévision va se va se coucher. Je veux
dire là tu vois très bien qu'en elle
sent en danger. Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Elle prend des mecs de ses news, elle
les met France info. Pourquoi elle fait
ça ? Pourquoi jeunis Bastier arrive à
France 2 ? Mais c'est pas pour rien
parce que
elle bosse bien peut-être. Oui,
peut-être elle bosse bien, mais si tu
veux, il tu vois bien qu'ils sont en
train de sentir l'arrivée éventuelle du
RN au pouvoir et ils sont en train de se
réorienter. Donc moi, je je suis ni pour
une France télévision macroniste, ni
pour une France télévision
mélanchoniste, ni pour une France
télévision bardiste. C'est pas ça le
sujet. C'est ça ça me saoule. Et
France Télévision journalistiquement
Ouais. Mais alors est-ce que voilà la
question de fond, est-ce que
l'audiovisuel public peut faire un
travail journalistique distancié du
pouvoir ? Franchement, enfin c'est quand
quand c'est arrivé en France depuis le
Gaulle, quand c'est arrivé ? Voilà,
jamais. Donc et le plus lunaire, c'est
que comme c'est évident que s'il y a un
dysfonctionnement majeur et que dans
n'importe quel pays étranger, on
regarderait ça, on dirait "Mais attends,
c'est une télévision d'État." Un jour
Schneerman a eu le malheur de dire
télévision d'État. Daniel, il malheur de
dire "C'est une télévision d'État." Il y
a toutes un mec de France 2 qui s'est
offusqué "Quais une télévision d'état,
pas du tout. Comment on pouvez dire ça
et tout ?" Mais stop. Enfin, pardon,
Daniel,
Daniel après Marc. Bon, donc oui, bah
malheureusement, c'est un peu des médias
d'état et et ça va pas. Et donc euh
c'est qu'il est retraité, hein.
Ouais, je sais. Non mais là là tu vois
tuas un mec de droite qui s'appelle à
l'oncle qui dit non mais ça va pas du
tout, c'est mal géré. Bon, il a plein
d'arguments entendables et puis il faut
que ça dépense un peu moins d'argent,
mais non, on va pas les privatiser. Mais
bon, enfin, ils sont en train de leur
mettre la pression. Mais qu'est-ce qui
va se passer à un moment donné s'il y a
un autre pouvoir politique de droite qui
arrive en France ? Bon bah, à mon avis,
ils vont pas tant que ça privatiser
France télé. Ils vont juste nommer des
cadres qui leur vont bien et ils vont
garder France télé. Mais pour moi, ça
sera le même problème que sous Macron.
C'est quel que soit le bord politique,
c'est un problème d'avoir un public qui
est pas indépendant. Alors, comme ça se
voit un peu trop, qu'est-ce qu'ils font
depuis des années ? Non, l'indépendance
est garantie. Tu as vu Delpin à la
commission l'important pour l'imitair
c'est l'indépendance c'est le truc
majeur c'est l'indépendance ça m'a fait
super marrer quoi.
Tu fais ça super bien
l'indépendance là je bien note he
attends je te le refire c'est
l'indépendance c'est ça qui mais arrêtez
d'avoir des mots horswéliens dans la
bouche. Vous dépendez du gouvernement
pour bouffer toute la journée quand vous
voulez faire les macronistes. C'est non
alors faut faire Sandrine Rousseaux ça
ça va. Chikirou ça va. Jordan Bardelas
ça va. Datiatal. Ah non ça va plus. Bon
en plus ils se font humiliés. Enfin, je
dis je dis pas ça de manière méprise.
J'ai vraiment des copains à France 2.
Mais comment tu peux quand tu veux faire
des portraits de macroniste, on te dit
"Ah non, mais là c'est pas possible."
[soupir]
Euh, comment tu peux être crédible quand
tu fais tous les opposants mais pas les
mecs qui sont au pouvoir ? C'est c'est
quand même lunaire quoi.
Attends 2 secondes, il y a le PSG qui a
marqué un but. [rires]
J'ai j'ai j'ai un fils de 13 ans qui
doit être en train de prendre son pied
devant faire le match. Ouais. Bisous. Je
donne pas son nom. On donne pas non plus
notre adresse de on est installé. On a
par clair. Euh, revenons à la commission
audiovisuelle.
Première question. Est-ce que toutes les
paroles se valent ?
Les paroles de qui ?
Bah, par exemple, tu fais des talk show.
Est-ce que il faut faire un cordon
sanitaire, ne pas inviter l'extrême
droite, ne pas Nous, on nous a reproché
hier d'avoir reçu Charles à l'oncle.
C'est un voilà c'est on doit pas
recevoir des mecs de droite. Il y a que
les mecs de gauche qui nous disent ça.
Ouais.
Les mecs de droite au départ de notre
chaîne quand on a reçu des mecs de
gauche, ils ont commencé à gueuler.
Bon bah on a reçu des mecs de gauche
jusqu'à plus soif. Ils ont compris hein.
Maintenant ils arrêtent quand on reçoit
un mec de gauche, ils savent que s'il
continuent à nous insulter ou insulter
l'invité ou
tu veux en inviter d'autres mecs de
gauche.
J'inviterai que des mecs de gauche
pendant pendant 2 mois 3 mois 4 mois et
plus il continue plus on a mis des mecs
de gauche et puis on a reçu un mec de
droite et on a eu les mecs de gauche qui
nous ont fait ça.
Voilà et on pensait que les mecs de
gauche ils étaient un petit peu plus
évolués
et non ils sont beaucoup plus sectaires.
Il te doc, ils t'insultent, ils ont des
copains journalistes qui vont ensuite
faire un article dégueulasse comme ça ça
va pouvoir faire changer ta fiche
Wikipédia. Tu vois, ils font des doses
Ouais. Non mais alors attends pour
rebondir sur ta question, est-ce que
toutes les paroles se valent ? Moi je
pense pas franchement. Enfin, je pense
qu'il y a des gens qui qui ce que
j'essaie de faire, j'arrive pas toujours
apparemment d'après toi, mais on essaie
de d'avancer sur des faits à peu près
documentés, établir.
Pourquoi tu as dit euh selon toi tu
non parce que quand je te fais part de
de de synthèses journalistiques qui qui
suivent des années d'investigation sur
un sujet, quand j'ai fait un bouquin sur
les médias, si tu veux des fois je je te
résume un peu Sarco Vivindi, Boloré, tu
me dis "Est-ce que tu es sûr ?" En fait,
on a beaucoup bossé donc oui, j'arrive à
te dire ça. Après, je te retrouve pas
exactement la page 228 où on a tout ce
qu'on a trouvé mais quand même voilà,
c'est important. Oui oui oui mais en
plus il faut être précis bien sûr il
faut être précis faut être nuancé faut
recouper faut être prudent quand c'est
des faits c'est des faits quand c'est
d'interprétation c'est l'interprétation
c'est ça qu' faut faire d'accord donc ça
ces parolesl elles ont de la valeur ok
après tu as aussi des gens qui racontent
de la purée bon
n'importe lawak voilà donc ça ça va pas
bon donc
par exemple je vais pas m'acharner sur
Nouna mais je pense que des fois il
raconte n'importe quoi. Bon je fais
cours parisieniste
il est pas journaliste
non il est pas journaliste. Il metteur
télé.
Voilà, il est metteur télé mais il parle
de l'actualité. C'est pratique mais il
est pas journaliste donc il fait ce
qu'il veut et cetera.
Oui mais non mais d'accord mais quand
quand tu prétends arbitrer l'affaire je
sais pas moi l'affaire de par Dieu
contre une compement d'enquête si tu
veux aller là-dedans, tu le fais tu le
fais avec un peu de vérification des
faits ou alors sinon moi je perds mon
temps à regarder ce ce ce je le
qualifierai pas. Bref, donc tout ça pour
dire que tout le temps les paroles se
valent pas. Après euh parmi des gens qui
qui sont à peu près dans un
fonctionnement consistant à essayer de
faire attention au fait de les vérifier,
de recouper, de s'ouvrir à des faits qui
peuvent déranger leur confort
intellectuel mais être sur des faits
mais open bar quoi. Je veux dire, on va
pas commencer à dire on va écouter que
ceux-là et pas les autres quoi. Il y a
pas de problème. Et mais mais le mais
pourquoi ? Moi je constate comme vous
que plein de gens s'accrochent à je
préfère entendre des gens qui pensent
comme moi. Bon pourquoi au fond ? Parce
que le cerveau humain quelque part c'est
confortable d'avoir des gens qui te
disent ce que tu penses déjà. Euh moi
par exemple, je suis en gros de gauche
et je me préoccupe de la planète. OK.
J'entends un mec de droite comme à
l'oncle par exemple que que j'ai écouté.
Bon a priori ça va un peu me bousculer.
C'est pas c'est pas le mec qui pense
comme moi. Donc c'est un peu moins
confortable intellectuellement d'écouter
quelqu'un qui a préré de l'autre bord.
Mais à l'oncle par exemple il a dit ben
Aurelien Saintoule de LFI, je trouve que
c'est un mec qui bosse bien fait du bon
boulot. Bon, regardez notre
[raclement de gorge] interview d'
Oui. Donc il a il a il a vu bosser
Saintoule, il dit "Bon bah c'est un mec
de l'fi, je suis désolé, il fait du taf
et cetera où Emeric Caron a demandé la
commission d'enquête sur Epstein. C'est
pas ma cam mais là-dessus il a raison.
Bah voilà. Bon c'est tout. Donc enfin ou
alors je sais pas on on fait des camps
puis on est tous dans des camps puis on
se parle jamais. Enfin c'est n'importe
quoi. Donc
tu as pas l'impression que si se parle
oui beaucoup. Puis bon voilà, tout le
monde lui est tombé dessus parce enfin
une partie de la presse de centre gauche
lui tombe dessus de manière très
violente alors qu'une partie de ses
journaux qui lui tombe dessus ont pour
actionnaire le monsieur qui l'a engueulé
Xavier lors de la commission d'enquête.
Donc tout ça c'est quand même lunaire en
terme de conflit d'intérêt et mais mais
voilà donc non toutes les paroles se
valent pas. Moi je pense que si on parle
d'information, on essaie d'être sur des
faits, il y a des gens sérieux, d'autres
qui ne sont moins. En revanche, d'avoir
des regards différents, ouais, ça
bouscule mais à un moment donné
l'intelligence humaine, elle peut pas
marcher si on n'est pas en train de se
confronter avec des idées différentes.
Donc moi, ça me gêne pas d'écouter un
mec qui est pas d'accord avec quoi he
dis une bonne dispute. Ouais, mais
éventuellement, tu sais, il y a quelques
années, il y a une émission, enfin sur
euh sur la 5 euh Berlusconi, c'était pas
Macam, mais il y avait un mec qui était
s'appelait Jean-Claude Bour qui était
pas non plus Macam, mais qui faisait des
duels absolument terribles entre deux
personnes pas du tout d'accord mais
franchement c'était super bien quoi. Et
deux mecs qui se déchiraient la gueule
pendant une demi-heure, c'était pas
d'accord. Mais moi je trouvais ça bien.
Donc euh oui, on confront des idées, on
n'est pas d'accord, c'est pas un
problème. Et de toute façon, il va tous
falloir qu'on vive ensemble dans cette
dans ce pays parce que sinon on va on va
virer l'autre bord politique dans la
mer, on va faire comment enfin je ou
alors on prend des flingues, on
s'entretue, tu vois. Non non non, il
faut il faut être calme, trouver un
consensus,
échanger les idées, essayer de trouver
un chemin pour résister euh
à une trajectoire qui est mal engagée
pour la France.
On essaie de s'insérer dans un cadre
commun en fait à l'oncle parler de la
République, enfin un cadre commun, c'est
je sais pas comment dire, on se met à
peu près d'accord sur des règles de base
qui vont faire qu'on va arriver à
fonctionner ensemble sans trop se
bouffer la gueule quoi. Donc
est-ce qu'on peut faire un petit peu de
rétrospective journalistique ?
Ouais.
Guerre du golfe numéro 2.
Ouais,
ça a bien été traité par tes confrères.
Oh là là ! 2003 ?
Euh ouais, il y a il y a la 91 et la
2003.
2003, j'étais à jeis à Bagdad la veille
de la du jour où ça a bombardé. Mais ça
va pas répondre à ta question parce que
c'était pas en fait sous les bombes, tu
réfléchis pas mieux que ailleurs. C'est
pas c'est pas très intéressant. Je sais
pas comment les médias ont traité la
guerre. En règle générale, moi ça fait
des années et des années que je trouve
qu'il y a un problème de distance par
rapport à à l'info. Mais par exemple
dans ce genre de grands conflits où il y
a des énormes puissances qui sont en
jeu, les journalistes nous enflent. La
vérité c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal
à accéder aux infos, beaucoup de mal à
accéder au terrain. Quand bien même tu
accèdes au terrain, bah tu es embedded.
Quand tu es pas
embed ça veut dire tu es embarqué dans
l'armée américaine blindé. C'est c'est
un petit safari photo tranquillou hein.
On te montre ce que tu veux. Enfin, tu
connais l'histoire, c'est qu'au moment
de la guerre du Vietnam, l'armée
américaine se méfiait pas tellement des
journalistes. Elle disait les gars open
bar, nos hélicoptères, c'est des bus
dedans. Tu veux aller voir là où ça tire
? Ben viens, je vais t'emmener. Tu
descends je te ramène au retour, pas de
problème. Les gens ils se bossaient.
Bon, au bout de quelques années, ils ont
tellement bossé qu'ils ont commencé à
filmer des horreurs. L'armée américaine
s'est dit ça devient compliqué. Il y a
l'opinion publique là derrière, ils ont
commencé à flipper, ça va pas. Ils ont
commencé à resserrer le truc. Bon, puis
maintenant ils ont compris hein. C'est
que tu es un bedud, tu pars dans les
blindés, on te fait le briefing au
départ, on te dit tu peux filmer ça mais
pas ça. C'est comme quand tu visites une
prison en France, ils ont fait le ménage
avant. Donc bon, tout le monde sait que
ça marche comme ça. Les puissances
importantes ont appris à contrôler la
presse. Donc est-ce que les confrères
ont bien traité 2003 ? Je sais pas, il y
en a plein qui ont essayer de faire le
job. Mais c'est très compliqué de
couvrir ce genre de conflit et encore
une fois dans des médias tenus soit par
des industriels qui peuvent avoir des
intérêts avec les politiques, soit par
un état qui est pas courageux parce que
bon, la France est quand même pas très
courageuse sur ces questions.
C'est pas la France he
c'est pas la France en l'occurrence
c'est les États-Unis.
Enfin, tu vois, encore une fois, le
biais de la propriété des médias pour
couvrir ce genre de conflit est un
problème, mais comme pour tout, mais
notamment là-dessus. En plus, couvrir
des guerres, ça coûte cher, faut envoyer
des mecs, faut des assurances. Bon,
c'est de l'argent. Qui veut mettre de
l'argent dans l'information en France ?
Vraiment, est-ce que l'État veut mettre
de l'argent dans l'information ? Si
c'était le cas, France 24 serait pas
dans l'état où ils sont. Quand Chirak a
créé France 24, il y avait quoi sur la
sur la planète ? Avait CNN, BBC,
Algzira. OK, c'est des gens qui ont des
millions d'euros de budget. BBC, ils ont
des bureaux partout dans le monde.
Alzira, il parle à 80 millions
d'arabisans, c'est des machines de
guerre et c'est des bons. Ils recrutent
les meilleurs. Bon, ils ont des budgets
à tomber. Chiraq, il arrive nous aussi
la France, on doit avoir une voix la
France machin, on va créer France 24.
OK. France 24 dépendant plus ou moins du
cador c'est financé par l'État. Bon et
on met 1 centiè du budget des autres tu
donné. Donc on veut couvrir les gares
correctement. Faut de l'argent. Il faut
de l'argent et il faut que les gens
puissent bosser librement. OK. Qui
fournit ça en France ? Des moyens et de
la liberté éditoriale il n'y a pas.
Nous, on a la liberté éditoriale, on n
pas l'argent. Eux, ils ont l'argent, on
pas la liberté éditoriale. Euh donc non,
je je je a un problème de couverture des
conflits. Évidemment,
on va prendre les questions internet.
Vas-y.
Parce que ça fait euh 1h47 qu'on est en
direct. Tu as pas envie de faire pipi ?
Ça va,
ça va, ça va. Je retiens.
Tu te retiens ?
Non, ça va ça. Franchement, c'est cool.
Donc, j'ai un message à la communauté.
Faites remonter les questions sur
Twitter avec des likes qu'on puisse
identifier directement
les burs questions que vous avez
sélectionné pour nous.
Alors vas-y, je t'en pose une le temps
que Montréal Montréal cherche les
questions.
J'ai une dernière question entre toi et
moi sur le les journalistes.
On nous emmerde tout le temps avec les
questions d'ingérance russe, Qatari,
des journalistes qui sont payés par les
popof pour faire passer des messages. Le
Maroc, c'est pas le Maroc qui avait un
petit peu soudoyé un journaliste sur BFM
? Oui.
Bon, tu as plein d'ingérences. Le
problème qu'on a nous, c'est qu'on est
en train de remonter des ingérences qui
sont soi-disant être nos alliés. Les
États-Unis faciles, mais l'Angleterre,
on te conseille d'aller creuser un petit
peu euh les rose beefs euh à partir de
2016. OK.
En terme d'ingérence.
Anglais.
Ouais.
Alors, regardons les questions. Je
prends la première. Bonsoir monsieur
Rivoir et Sky. Que pensez-vous de
l'école de journalisme rachetée par des
oligarques français ? que vaudra la
qualité et la rigueur de l'information
transmise au public par ces journalistes
pour interrogation. Merci.
[soupir] Euh oui, Boloré plus je sais
plus qui ont remis de l'argent dans une
école de journalisme privée à Paris dont
ils vont prendre le contrôle. Bon, je
pense pas que ça va donner des miracles.
Après, il y a toujours du miracle chez
les humains qui font des études. Des
fois, il y a des gens très bien dans des
écoles dont les propriétaires sont pas
forcément très bien. Donc, je pense pas
que ça va changer grand-chose. Euh, les
écoles de journalisme en général. Alors,
je te pose une question un peu plus
Attends, on Pourquoi tu does des lignes
de la tête ? Moi, j'ai fait le centre de
formation des journalistes en 91, donc
une bonne écoles parisienne qui m'a
formé de manière intéressante et
quelques temps avant, je crois François
Ruffin il était passé, il avait trouvé
que vraiment on formait des petits
soldats du journalisme et il l'avait
dénoncé dans un bouquin. Bon, après que
je sois parti du CFJ, je sais que TF1 a
pris un peu le contrôle du CFJ, ils ont
mis des mecs à eux. Bon, en fait le
problème de ces écoles, je pense que
plein de gens essayent de bien faire le
boulot de former les étudiants. Le
problème, c'est que ils forment les
étudiants pour faire quoi ? Pour aller
où ? Si si quand tu sors, tu vas dans
des médias euh qui sont soumis
[grognement] à des intérêts qui sont pas
ceux de l'information, bah les pauvres
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent. Ils
souffrent, ils essayent, ils faire du
bon boulot, parfois ils y arrivent, mais
c'est un enfer de de propriété des
médias. Donc moi, je pense c'est pas
tellement un problème de formation. Et
d'ailleurs, moi j'en fréquente he des
étudiants d'école journalistes parce que
souvent ils sont chez nous ensuite en
alternance ou quoi, ils nous disent "Bah
dis donc, il y a pas beaucoup de
débouchés ou alors ils nous disent "J'ai
pas envie d'aller à BFM TV ou à C News".
Je dis ouais, tu as raison, on vient
dans les médias ind mais après les
médias indés, on est on est 5 6 7 ils me
disent tuembauches je dis bah j'aimerais
bien. Enfin tu vois, on n pas beaucoup
d'embauche. Il y a un blast se se
solidifie un peu, le média s'écroule un
peu. Nous, on essaie de se développer
mais parti du monde hein, c'est c'est
c'est les kings, ils ont 220000 2500
abonnés, je sais pas combien mais il y a
pas beaucoup d'embauche. Et donc le
problème des étudiants en journalisme,
c'est que par exemple moi j'ai quelqu'un
de proche qui me dit "Mais va faire un
peu des cours dans les écoles de
journalisme."
Ouais, peut-être, mais pour former des
gens qui vont à 80 % terminer dans les
grands médias privés ou dans le service
public où ils pourront pas toujours
bosser, enfin correctement en fait,
c'est quoi l'idée en fait ? Donc moi, je
pense qu'il faut révolutionner le
système de la presse euh et que c'est
pas tellement un problème d'école de
journalisme. D'ailleurs, nous on sert
d'école aussi hein. Dans les on forme
des gens.
Le fait que la partie droite
chope des facs, la partie droite
commence à choper son école de
journalisme, c'est quoi ? C'est une
réaction de la droite à une main mise
qui a été tenue pendant des années dans
un seul sens ou une seule façon de faire
et ou sinon ils ont décidé de se faire
leur propre école pour pouvoir former
leur propre journaliste pour leur propre
médias plus tard.
Oui. Alors bon tu tu auras tu auris
l'idée que tous les journalistes serient
de gauche. Moi je suis pas d'accord. Il
y en a plein qui sont de droite.
Je rel pas l'idée. Je pose la question.
OK. Bon, imaginons qu'une partie des
juristes sont de gauche, ça c'est vrai.
Peut-être une partie majoritaire, j'en
sais rien, et que certain nombre de gens
de droite veulent faire une une reprise
en main culturelle de ce métier en forme
et j'ai quand je les écoute, c'est pas
une reprise en main culturelle, c'est
être équilibré,
d'accord,
et fairplay.
OK. Donc former des journalistes plus
compatibles avec les médias de droite
pour écrier et ce
pas compatible, c'est un c'est équilibré
le respect de la charte de Munique.
Point mar.
Alors moi moi j'ai pas de problème à ce
que le le la profession de journaliste
soit équilibrée politiquement. Ça me ça
me dérange pas du tout.
Après
je sais pas pourquoi il faut que Boloré
prenne le contrôle d'une école de
journalisme pour qu'enfin il y ait
quelques journalistes de droite.
Peut-être quand même ailleurs. Mais bon
peu importe. C'est surtout que
l'équilibre politique droite gauche. Oui
peut-être. Ça c'est pour moi c'est pas
tellement un sujet. C'est plutôt enfin
moi le premier truc que je regarde c'est
pas si le mec il est droite ou si est
gauche. C'est comment il bosse quoi. Moi
j'ai vu des journalistes remarquables
dans cette profession, des anglais, des
gens comme ça qui sur des sujets donnés
faisaient un travail remarquable. Euh je
pense notamment à un confrère du
Guardian qui au moment de la sale guerre
en Algérie
du Guardian
euh ouais je crois un mec du Guardian un
mec qui était enfin un reporter
remarquable. Bon, au moment de la sale
guerre en Algérie 882004, tu as un
pouvoir militaire qui va interrompre un
processus électoral remporté par
l'islamiste de sévir, tuer 200000
personnes et enlever 20000 qui vont
disparaître. Une guerre terrible. Voilà
92000 chef cours dans ce bordel de
propagande de désinformation et
d'infiltration du terrorisme et de
manipe des services secrets. On est
quelquesuns en France à essayer d'y voir
clair et il y a un journaliste anglais
qui fait un boulot remarquable. Je sais
pas moi si le mec il est droite ou de
gauche, je m'en fous. En fait, il a fait
un travail qui consiste non pas à dire
"J'explique tout depuis Londres, mais je
vais sur place, je crois pas tout ce
qu'on me dit, je vais voir des victimes,
je vais voir des gens, je recoupe. J'ai
le courage d'aller voir des gens qui me
disent "Putain, mais les services
secrets nous ont enflés" et cetera. Et
je leur ramène des papiers, on me
fouille mes affaires, on m'enlève mes
carnets, je planque mes affaires, je
planque mes cartes SD, je sors quand
même, je les emmerde, j'envoie mes
éléments, je reviens à Londres et je
fais ce que j'ai envie de dire. Bon et
ben ça c'est pas tout le monde hein.
Donc parce que je te prends juste un
exemple, les gens français quand ils
voulaient aller en Algérie pendant cette
seule guerre pour traiter le truc euh
dans les grandes chaînes de télévision
quand tu étais accepté par Alger, on te
donnait un visa et cetera, on te
surveillait comme le lait sur le feu. Tu
allais à Alger sur un bassac, sur un
truc, tu faisais un compte-endu qui
était pas tout à fait ce que attendaient
les autorités algériennes. La fois
d'après, tu avais plus le visa. Donc les
mecs, ils essayaient de jongler pour
quand même continuer à conserver le visa
sans trop les vexer, tout en essayant de
pas trop mentir. Mais c'est pas possible
en fait. Donc moi, j'ai fait un
reportage en 96 en Algérie en pleine
salle guerre avec une journaliste
algérienne. Comme j'étais blanche, je
flippais. C'était très dur. Je me
suisint en brun, j'ai pris une camérière
dans un sac. On voyait pas que j'étais
journaliste, je suis mon avec une
bagnole d'un algérien et une journaliste
algérienne et j'ai fait gens j'étais
rebeux, tu vois. On a pu un tout petit
peu travailler. Sauf qu'en fait non, ils
étaient plus malins que nous. Ils ont
collé des escortes parce qu'on était la
télé M6 escorte pour nous surveiller.
Dès qu'on parlait à des jeunes dans la
rue, je parle même pas de la situation
de guerre, des jeunes qui dilaient un
peu du marché noir qui disaient "Putain,
les flics ils nous tapent et cetera."
L'escort leur parlait en arabe en leur
disant je ne comprenais pas parce que
moi je parle un peu arabe mais pas
beaucoup. Le mec devenait complètement
blem et je pense que le cuf de l'escorte
lui a dit si tu dis encore un mot devant
la télévision française je te tue et
j'égorge tes parents. C'est comme ça que
ça marche en Algérie. Donc moi ça m'a
énervé. J'étais à l'hôtel or assagger.
J'appelais ma copine disait il nous
casse les couilles on peut pas bosser.
Donc un soir je dis ma copine algérienne
c'est ce qu'on va faire j'ai envie qu'on
aille à Blida voir des victimes. Je sais
pas de quoi ils ont été victimes mais
j'ai envie qu'il nous raconte. Donc on
va sortir parce que là c'est le soir il
y a plus l'escorte. Tu vois, on descend
dans le hall de la Torassie avec avec
Fausia, on est con nous, tu vois. On
descend, je me dis, on va se casser
Discros, on va aller à Blida, tu vois,
on traverse le hall de l'hôtel 5
étoilass assis, tuas un mec voté dans un
canapé, il se lève et fait vous allez où
? Je fais "Excuse-moi, excuse-moi, je
vous ai pris pour des cons en fait. Vous
êtes en train de nous surveiller même la
nuit." OK, donc on va nulle part, on va
fumer une clope en fait, [rires] tu peux
pas sortir et quand bien même on serait
sorti en défiance des escortes, ce qui
est quand même très compliqué en Algérie
dans cette sale guerre, tu vas voir des
habitants de Blida qui vont vider leur
cœur, te raconter leur histoire, prendre
un risque, tu leur dit "Je te jure, je
vais te flouter quand je vais rentrer à
Paris. Quand je vais rentrer à Paris, je
vais te flouter." À l'époque tu avais
des cassettes. L'escort te repèrent, tu
passes à la douine, ils prennent des
cassettes, terminées, les autorités
interceptent les gens qui ont parlé,
c'est fini. Donc la pression sur les
victimes dans ce genre de situation,
elle est absolument terrible. Et donc
moi je rentre de ce reportage pour M6 en
septembre 96 un peu naïvement. Je me
bats avec l'agentiste algérienne pour
dire il faut qu'on dise qu'on nous a
empêché de bosser que ça était pas
possible c'est insupportable. Elle me
dit non on va pas le dire. Tu as Patrick
de Carolis qui arbitre qui dit bon ok il
a un peu raison on va quand même dire
que vous avez été fliqué. Ça expliquera
pourquoi vous avez pas pu bosser. Et
après 96 plus jamais j'étais autorisé
d'aller en Algérie. Plus jamais ils ont
répondu à mes demandes de visa. Et donc
on quand on voulait bosser sur parce que
l'année d'après 97 des grands massacres
qui commencent à la banque d'Alger. Donc
c'est un vrai sujet. Comment on fait ?
Soit on prend des gens qui sortent et
qui racontent, soit on envoie des
équipes clandestinement en Algérie. Donc
on se bat comme des chiens. Moi un jour
on envoie pour Canadal un algérien avec
une copine française qui se déguise en
Europe Kaby pour aller enquêter sur
l'assassinat du chanteur Lunes Matou en
Kabili dans le village où il a été tué.
On apprend qu'un habitant du village qui
a vu des militaires tourner autour a été
faire le tourner des témoins avec un
pauvre magnétophone qu'il a envoyé sa
pauvre cassette à Amnestia International
dans ayant peur qu'on le tue. On
récupère cette cassette, on envoie une
équipe clandestinement là-bas et sans se
faire repérer par les tous les mecs de
la Stasie de l'Algérie qui sont là-bas,
on essaie d'aller voir les gens. On dit
"Bah [__] qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
On recueille des témoignages pour
confirmer, recouper ce qu'il y a dans la
cassette. On arrive à sortir un truc sur
la mer de Matou." Mais je veux dire,
c'est un combat, c'est un combat de
dingue l'information. C'est pas je fais
mon plateau, ça va, je vous dérange pas,
j'aurai mon visa. Non, on a envoyé des
équipes clandestinement canal le courage
de faire ça à un moment donné. Mais
c'est ça le journalisme en fait dans les
zones de guerre. C'est comme ça que ça
se passe quand Aniva enquête sur la
guerre en Tetchenie machin, je sais pas
quoi. Elle s'habille en Tetchen, elle
parle russe et elle parle 3 mois
clandestinement dans les régions où ça
se passe et elle parle avec les Tchchen
et les Russes. Elle parle russe. Elle
ramène des trucs. Moi quand je bossais
en Russie il y a 15 ans, je bosse avec
Manon l'oiseau qui vit à Moscou qui a
une mère anglaise et qui parle russe
couramment et qui ambiance les mecs au
checkpoint les soldats russes et on
passe parce que une facilité de de
s'infiltrer, de passer de faire parce
que la vérité faut aller la chercher. Tu
sais pas depuis mon hôtel avec mon
plateau que je vais la trouver. Donc euh
c'est voilà, c'est une bagarre ce métier
permanente et si on fait pas cette
bagarre, on se fait enfler et si on se
fait enfler, on enflé millions de gens
derrière. Donc voilà, ça qui est
énervant.
Respect mec. Alors question que je
découvre avec toi. Euh tu l'as tu l'as
prélu non ? Alors vous voyez comment le
futur du journalisme notamment avec
l'émergence de l'intelligence
artificielle, est-ce que c'est un outil
que vous serez amené à utiliser et quels
seront les usages pour interrogation ?
Est-ce que quelque chose qui pourrait
fortement Est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait fortement vous desservir ?
Ouais, moi je suis un peu méfiant. Bon,
je je suis un peu âgé en même temps. Je
bientôt la retraite tout ça. Si si, je
te jure. Non, mais l'intelligence
artificielle, moi je sais pas ce que
c'est. C'est pas mon truc, je m'en méfie
comme de la peste. Voilà. Et en tout
cas, dans le métier qu'on fait,
franchement, c'est un métier d'humain et
d'humain honnêtes. C'est pas juste des
humains, c'est des humains honnêtes.
Donc, c'est compliqué. Donc
l'intelligence artificielle, le secours.
Après euh je veux pas non plus être
débile. Euh peut-être ça peut nous aider
comment dire par exemple moi des gens
qui bossent un peu avec me disent "Bah
tu vois, tu as un rapport de de 600
pages, c'est chiant à lire. Tu le mets
dans une IA, ça te ressort une fiche
avec la synthèse du rapport. Je pense ça
peut faire gagner du temps à des
journalistes qui se gavent des des
heures et des heures et des heures
d'audition de machin de truc. Après, de
toute façon, à un moment donné euh
enfin, on va pas écrire des articles
avec l'intelligence artificielle, c'est
un boulot subjectif, personnel de
confiance. Moi, je suis pas d'accord
avec Vincent Boller qui effaceent les
noms des journalistes dans ces journaux
gratuits pour qu'ils apparaissent pas et
qu'on puisse réécrire leurs papiers sans
qu'ils aient rien à dire. C'est
dégueulasse. Il faut faire tout le
contraire. Faut que ce soit des gens qui
assument ce qu'ils font, qui disent
qu'ils sont, qui disent de de quoi ils
parlent et qui assument leur signature
et qui fassent même les papiers. Et s'il
se plantent, ils se plantent et ils sont
punis. S'il se plantent pas, ils se
plantent pas. Donc moi, je suis pas un
fan de l'artigérance artificielle quoi.
Mais tu m'as fait sauter les questions
toi. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Désolé pour
le petit.
Ils sont sûr, ils sont les questions.
Non, allez, par-toi. Euh, il y avait une
question qui était relativement
intéressante. Je vais lire celle-ci là.
Bonsoir. Pourquoi le journalisme
d'investigation n'intéresse plus les
gens ? Ah bon ? C'est une info ça.
Alors, ça c'est marrant, c'est un truc
qu'on nous a souvent dit dans les
chaînes de télé ou c'est un peu la mode
si à France Télévision. Non, mais
l'investigation ça marche pas. C'est ce
qu'a dit par exemple Takis Scandilis un
grand cadre de de la une qui avait été
recruté par Air en 2017 quand Macron
mettait la pression sur Airne pour
qu'elle arrête de faire chier qu'elle
dépense moins d'argent. Elle a pris des
gens dans le privé et tuis scandalist il
est arrivé en disant non mais les gens
l'information ça les intéresse plus et
cetera. D'ailleurs ils ont fait un truc
de fou. France Télévision à l'époque
commandait près de 1200 heures de
documentaires par an. Donc faut savoir
que l'info à France télé, tu as 1200
heures de documentaires, plein de cases
documentaires et puis tu as les
magazines d'actualité qui sont connus
envoyé spécial, complément cash et
cetera qui sont moins important en terme
d'heure de programme. Elle a essayé
d'externaliser envoyé spécial les
compléments d'enquête dans le privé.
Elle s'est pris une fronde à la partie.
Elle s'est pris une mesure de défiance
air, on est en 2017. Qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait ? Elle dit à tous les producteurs
de documentaire de Paris, "Alors
l'investigation,
non, c'est déjà dans les cases de Valex
et de Lucet. Donc chez vous non. Donc en
fait, tu as 1200 heures de documentaire,
faut plus faire d'enquête. Mais tu fais
quoi en fait ? Enfin, tu fais plus
d'investigation. Pourquoi ? C'est quoi
le problème ? Ouais, l'investigation
c'est un peuxène, ça marche pas. On nous
a sorti 15 conneries. Faut faire du
jourme positif, de construction. Bref,
tout est fait pour dire stop les
enquêtes, ça fait chier. C'est
clairement ça. Alors, ça coûte un peu
d'argent mais en vrai, ça coûte moins
qu'un téléfilm. Donc non,
l'investigation ça marche pas. C'est pas
vrai du tout. En fait, c'est tout le
contraire. L'investigation ça marche.
C'est plébiscité par le public. Ils
attendent que ça. Ils ont juste besoin
qu'on leur dise la vérité sur des sujets
y compris quand ça dérange. Et là ça
marche très fort. Quand Valex fait dans
complément d'enquête une enquête sur
Mimi Marchand, la communiquante
confidentielle du couple Macron qui est
une ancienne trafiquante de drogue qui
est un voyou absolu qui a essayé
d'arranger les affaires de Sarco au
Liban enfin j'en passe et des meilleurs.
Il fait le carton d'audience de l'année.
Les gens adorent qu'on aille dans les
coulisses du pouvoir mais à condition de
bosser dire la vérité. Donc
l'investigation ça marche. On la tue pas
parce qu'elle marche pas. On la tue
parce qu'elle dérange. C'est pas pareil.
Question internet. Est-ce que vous vous
sentez libre de publier tous vos
articles ? Quelles sont vos contraintes
? Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as
d'autocensure censure chez toi ? Alors
euh,
comment [grognement] dire, on essaie de
pas en avoir. Euh le fait d'avoir coupé
tous les fils à la pâte qui pourrai
exister en terme de gens qui nous
feraiit des pressions, bah comme vous,
ça consiste à se dire déjà, on va
enlever tous les emmerdeurs. OK, on
dépend de la population qui nous
finance. On peut avoir des gens, des
citoyens qui nous financent, qui nous
engueulent en disant "Non mais ça c'est
pas bien, faut pas le faire et cetera."
Bonus, enfin c'est pas que je m'en fous,
j'aime bien, je respecte les gens, je
regarde ce qu'ils disent et cetera. Je
reprends, je m'en fous pas. Mais ce que
je veux dire c'est queà un moment donné
quand on fait ce boulot et qu'on est
payé toute la journée, même pas beaucoup
pour regarder l'actualité, développer
une expertise, comprendre un truc, bah
si on pense que ça c'est pertinent comme
sujet, que c'est intéressant, faut y
aller, je vais pas demander non plus à
des gens que je connais pas s'il faut
que je le fasse. Donc on y va. Donc on n
pas tellement de de contraintes. Là où
nous on a pu sentir quand même qu'on a
un peu réfléchi pour dire les choses
poliment, c'est pour des
dire pas poliment s'il te plaît.
Ouais. Là où on s'est dit là où on a un
peu réfléchi ces dernières années mais
en fait on l' fait quand même c'est
est-ce qu'on peut explorer sans
concession le système de la presse
française ? [rires]
Voilà je te prends juste un exemple. Par
exemple un jour on on travaille sur
comment les 5 milliardaires de la presse
se sont comportés par rapport au
candidat Emmanuel Macron entre 2012 et
2017. OK. Bon et ce que vous voulez
voter pour Macron, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Alors tuas tu as Libé, c'est ça ?
C'est la de Libé là, faites ce que vous
voulez mais voter pour Macron contre
Marine. Enfin bon, le mec qui te dit
qu'il faut voter, c'est lunaire. Bon euh
ils ont pas tous été pour Macron dès le
départ puisque par exemple Bernard
Arnaud a plutôt misé sur François
Fillon, je crois. Enfin bon, mais quand
même globalement au bonhomman, ils
sentent que c'est Macron qui va monter.
Ils soutiennent tous Macron.
Bon, quand on fait délinquant et ultra
riche, comment ils ont fait Éliir Macron
en parlant de tous ces milliardaires
qu'on fait un peu enfin qu'on contribue
à faire Macron parce que c'est le peuple
français qui l'a élu mais quand même ils
ont beaucoup poussé.
On regarde la stratégie d'influence et y
compris un monsieur qui s'appelle Xavier
Niel pas que lui mais aussi lui, il y a
pas de raison de l'épargner. C'est pas
parce que c'est le mec qui tient le
monde qui faut l'épargner. Donc on fait
Bernard Rado, Patrick Dra, Saadé et
Xavier Niel. Le journaliste qui traite
le sujet me dit "Waouh, Niel c'est
chaud." Bon, il a un passé un peu
trouble dans le minitel rose, il a un
peu abusé auprès de ses hôesses
téléphoniques et cetera. Bon, je vous
fais cours mais le journaliste me dit
c'est chaud quand même Niel. Je dis
pourquoi ? Bah c'est l'OPS, ça c'est le
monde, c'est tous les talk show
politiques de France télé. Enfin en
gros, un jeune journaliste de centre
gauche aujourd'hui se fumer Niel c'est
un peu dangereux tu vois
potentiellement. D'ailleurs euh cette
remarque là de quelqu'un qui disait euh
que les gens du monde avaient dit "Toi,
tu bosseras plus en France" ou Lancelin
racontait aussi que les gens d'autour de
Niel sont capables de dire "Si nous on
décide que tu travailles plus, tu
travailles plus, enfin, ils se sentent
quand même tout-puissants les gens de ce
groupe de presse parmi d'autres." Donc
voilà, nous les jeunes jouristes qui
commencent leur carrière en se fumant
les médias, ils prennent des risques,
donc on réfléchit. Euh et euh je pense
que ceux qui ont signé des gros docs
chez nous là-dessus, bah ils se disent
"C'est pas demain matin que je vais être
embrouché euh dans les grands médias
publics par exemple euh ni
éventuellement au monde." Donc c'est une
prise de risque. Donc faut pas qu'on se
casse la gueule demain parce que sinon
les mecs ils bosent plus tu vois. Donc
euh on est un peu en danger. Il y a il y
a [gémissement][grognement]
les mecs d'ultradroite sur internet, ils
ont un penseur qui s'appelle Alain
Soral. Hm
hm. Et lui dit une journal un
journaliste c'est soit une [__] soit un
chômeur.
Ouais. Voilà. À propos nuancé Alain
Soral.
Euh non mais je sais pas ce qu'il veut
dire, je le connais pas mais clairement
on connait pas non plus hein.
Ouais. Non mais clairement
il a dit qu'on était des des agents
secrets et un jour on passe le la
frontière d'un pays un peu chelou et les
mecs avaient vu sa vidéo.
Bon,
on n pas eu une petite fouille de
l'ampoule mais ils nous ont regardé de
travers.
Bon donc il doit être écouté à
l'étranger. OK. Non mais en fait je je
sais pas ce qu'il veut dire mais ce que
ce que j'entends dans cette phrase c'est
soit on a une [__] soit on est chômeur.
C'est en gros soit on soit on accepte de
travestir l'honnêteté du métier, soit on
bosse pas. Bon euh c'est un peu ce que
tu t'as dit tu'as dit juste avant
malheureusement. euh
comment dire ? Enfin, c'est c'est
toujours trop réducteur, toujours
pareil. Mais ce qui est vrai, c'est que
le problème de la propriété de
l'information en France pose un problème
de voilà de de de de liberté de l'info.
Et donc euh moi je je pense voilà, je
suis désolé pour les copains qui bossent
dans ces grands médias, je pense qu'on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui dans de bonnes
conditions renouveler la presse
française en travaillant dans ces
conditions-là. Et encore une fois, bien
sûr, tous les actionnaires sont pas les
mêmes. Je veux dire, il y en a qui sont
plus interventionnistes que d'autres. Il
y en a, ça se voit plus que d'autres, il
y en a c'est moins que d'autres. Mais
peu importe, euh quelqu'un qui a une
grande entreprise industrielle en France
téléphonique ou autre va pas prendre le
contrôle de je sais pas combien de
journaux parfois déficitaires juste pour
leur faire plaisir. C'est pas vrai qu'on
arrête de nous baratiner. C'est pas
vrai. Donc c'est de la presse, c'est de
l'influence. à partir du moment où c'est
de l'influence que que le mec utilise le
journal pour l'influence plus ou moins
ou pas trop ou un peu, c'est déjà une
position ingérable pour les journalistes
et d'ailleurs les médias indépendant qui
se crée globalement je trouve qu'ils ont
une une tenue euh journalistique
globalement infiniment meilleure que que
ces grands médias notamment audiovisuel.
Tu as parlé de Niel de votre famille la
famille d'assaut
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Bon, le patriarche, il est mort un peu,
hein.
Non, je rigole parce que ça me fait
penser à un truc.
P à son âme.
Ouais.
Serge Dasso a eu quelques problèmes de
chantage installé par des jeunes de
Corbeillasson qui voulaient le faire
chanter.
Ouais, il avait acheté un peu les voix
euh à une époque pour rester sénateur et
par ailleurs, quelques jeunes de la
région de Corbayasson disent que non
seulement il a acheté des voies mais que
par ailleurs parfois il allait un peu
dans des dans des dans des sites et dans
des appartements se faire des petits
plaisirs aussi.
Ouais. Non mais ça c'est pas prouvé,
c'est cool porter la calomie. Attention
hein,
ce qu'on a appris nous c'est que il y
avait eu un nettoyage de de d'un certain
nombre de jeunes de Corbeille qui
faisaient vraiment chier d'assaut. Il y
a eu à un moment donné un tir, il y a eu
un mec qui a tiré sur un autre retre et
cetera. Il y a eu un fait divers assez
grave entre les enfin quand il y a eu
une tension très forte entre d'assaut
les mecs qui l'avait arrosé les les voix
et les mecs qui menaçaient de le faire
chanter ça a commencé à chauffer et il y
a eu des gens qui sont venus faire un
peu le ménage pour protéger Serge
d'assaut qui apparemment on
c'est sourcé c'est étayé
c'est un témoignage qu'on m'a raconté
d'un mec de très bonne source qui est un
marchand d'armes français marchand
d'arme français qui est mort qui qui
était au cœur des contrats d'armement en
France et qui connaissait bien des gens
très très proches du système
qui leur on raconté par exemple que pour
nettoyer Corbason, il y a des
des des types qui pour processus
d'assaut ont été enlevés un peu les deux
trois mecs qui faisaient chier, les ont
embarqué dans la forêt, ils ont attaché
des arbres, leur faire croire qu'ils
allaient les tuer et puis ça les a
calmé, ils les ont pas tué hein. Après
les mecs ont tellement flippé, ils sont
repartis dans le gérimonde. Voilà, il y
a eu un nettoyage de Corbillon pour
protéger d'assous à un moment donné.
C'est pour ça que je rigolais mais bon,
c'est pas drôle en fait. Quelle était ta
question ? Le Dassou maintenant
oligarque. Les Dassou maintenant il ils
sont propriétaires de médias, pas de
médias. Comment ça se passe ? J'ai pas
trop suivi. C'est quoi ? C'est les
enfants d'assaut.
Bah
c'est encore le Figaro.
Alors
bah j'ai pas révisé, je sais pas.
Encore d'autres oligarques ?
Bah d'asso je pense que ça appartient
encore au groupe. Enfin le Figaro, je
veux dire. Oui. Donc c'est c'est quoi la
question ? C'est un peu la même logique.
Est qu'ils sont plus libres, moins
libres par rapport aux autres oligarques
les d'assaut. Non, ceux qui bossent pour
les Dassau,
les journalistes qui bossent pour les
Dassu. Bah je
Qui bossent pour le canard qui est
propriétaire des Dassau.
J'en sais rien. Moi, je b pas Figaro,
mais j'imagine que la la problématique
est la même. Encore une fois avec des
nuances. Je connais pas les niveaux de
nuances. Moi je bosse pas dans ces
journaux, je sais pas dans quelle mesure
au monde à l'OPS ou Figaro ou chez Saadé
ou chez je sais pas qui ou chez
Krétinski, je sais pas dans quelle
mesure l'actionnaire tient court, la
laisse, je ne sais pas. Euh ça
ou la tient pas du tout.
Ouais. Alors c'est ça, moi j'y crois pas
en fait.
Bénéfice du doute.
Non non c'est ça, moi j'y crois pas. le
côté non mais enfin comment oui un
actionnaire mais enfin on est
complètement libre et tout enfin pardon
moi ça me fait doucement enfin faut
arrêter quoi. Je suis désolé
l'actionnaire il va pas mettre enfin
est-ce que Bernard Arnaud remet 50
millions d'euros dans le Parisien tous
les 3 ans pour faire plaisir aux
journalistes c'est un mécen Bernard
Arnaud il adore la presse bah attends
c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est un philotrope
c'est des outils d'influence ça veut pas
dire qu'il les utilise tout le temps
pour faire une influence mais tu sais
comment ça se passe. Il suffit que tu
possèdes un grand quotidien ou une radio
ou je sais pas quoi. Tu te remets que
les politiques, ils vont te dire bonjour
poliment et si tu demandes un
rendez-vous à l'Élysée, tu vas la voir
parce que ils savent que tu as une
radio. Bon alors après, tu t'en sers de
manière plus ou moins perverse mais tu
t'en sers pour de l'influence. Bon à
partir de là, le jour où tu as un jour
qui découvre un truc qui emmerde le
président que tu veux préserver, tu vas
dire à ton journaliste bah excuse-moi,
ton papier il m'embête donc non en fait.
Et puis le mec, il faut qu'il paye son
loyer. Donc il va dire bon bah ok, je
vais pas faire mon papier. Enfin voilà,
enfin on tourne mais je veux dire c'est
toujours pareil, la propriété des médias
est un problème et euh le pouvoir
politique ne veut pas l'affronter, ne
veut pas le traiter quoi.
Allez, dernière question d'internet.
Bonsoir. Un petit exercice de pensée. On
fait une expérience de pensée ensemble.
D'accord. Pensez-vous qu'un milliardaire
journaliste de profession à la tête d'un
média ferait de ce dernier un média
indépendant ?
Alors, un milliardaire journaliste à la
tête d'un média ferait-il de ce média un
média indépendant ? Alors, il serait pas
indépendant de lui puisqu'il est
l'actionnaire et qu'il est milliardaire.
Donc, il serait pas indépendant de lui.
Bon, donc le patron du média, il dirige
le média si c'est ça la question. Après,
bah indépendant, ça dépend comment il
est financé parce que dans la question
il manque une info. Le mec, il est
milliardaire, il écrit un média. OK,
mais c'estàd qu'il fait vivre le média
avec ses milliards ou ça veut dire qu'il
trouve un modèle économique ? S'il
trouve un modèle économique, c'est
lequel ? C'est la pub. Il dépend des
annonceurs. C'est un médiia public, il
dépend de l'État. C'est
pas parler de Mathieu Pigas.
Et bien Pigas, ouais, banquier chez
Lazar qui a le groupe Nova et et les
ARC. Bah voilà, un milliardaire qui
trouve que c'est bien d'être de gauche,
ça en fait un. Euh la question c'est
quoi ? Est-ce que c'est bien Pigas ? Bah
c'est toujours pareil dans l'esprit de
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure. Pigas,
ça rééquilibre un peu parce que en fait
il protège des humoristes qui se foutent
un peu de la gueule de la droite. Donc
bon, moi je trouve ça fait un peu du
bien. Et puis en plus, ils ont un
certain succès public. qui sont fait
virer de France Inter. Donc voilà, après
Mérien contre Pigas he puis tant mieux
pour eux Nova tout ça. Après c'est
toujours pareil enfin eux-mêmes en sont
conscients. On a fait des interviews là
pour Noc sur le rire. Ils te disent bah
ils te disent Pigas c'est bien mais
demain matin il change d'avire il change
de toi il y a le vent qui tourne machin.
Il se passe quoi en fait ? Donc ils sont
hyper dépendants. Alors chez France
Inter il dépendait de siveille d'vanrit
là il dépend de de Mathieu. Bon super
tant que Mathieu ça va tu vois. Enfin,
moi j'ai eu envie de sortir de ces
genres de dépendan quoi, c'est tout. Et
après euh c'est comme vous, c'estàd que
je sais pas combien vous rentrez
d'argent par mois, par vos donateurs,
mais on rentre pas beaucoup par rapport
à Pigas, pas grand chose.
Voilà, on rentre des clopinettes par
rapport à Pigas, mais est-ce qu'on a
besoin forcément d'avoir des millions
d'euros ? Je fais juste un truc, faut
que les gens sachent aussi. Il y a 30
ans, tu voulais faire de la presse, en
gros, tu faisais de la presse écrite.
Fallait non seulement une [__] de
rédaction, une imprimerie, du papier et
le distribuer, c'est hors de prix. Donc,
fallait des millions d'euros pour
investir, pour créer un journal et tu
voulais faire l'audiovisuel, fallait des
satellites, des télés, des machins, des
trucs. Bon, la révolution technologique,
elle est lunaire quand même. C'estàd que
Media Part, c'est numérique, ça coûte
pas ni d'imprimerie, ni de distribution,
ni de papier. Et nous on fait de
l'audiovisuel comme vous avec des
caméras à 1500 balles. Des
non, celle-ci coûte beaucoup plus cher
hein.
Ouais, parce que vous êtes des stars
mais nous c'est des petites caméras et
des mac et on a on vient de finir de
l'amortir
voilà et des macinosch à 1000 balles et
on diffuse sur YouTube. Donc on a besoin
de ni de satellite. Enfin moi quand j'ai
commencé la télé il y a 30 ans, je veux
dire la caméra elle coûtait je sais pas
80000 €. Je sais parce qu'un jour à
l'aéroport de Benozer, il y en a un il a
poussé son pied, il a poussé ma bête à
cam pour me la piquer. J'ai failli
tomber dans les pommes et faire virer
par Herv Chabalier de capa. Donc je
sais, j'ai j'ai couru pour rattraper la
caméra, ça m'a fait flipper. Donc ça
valait cher. On dormait avec comme un
fusil, tu vois comme ça. Bon aujourd'hui
ça vaut 1000 balles, donc faut pas se la
faire piquer. Mais tu te la faire
piquer, c'est moins grave. le montage
des bandes montage c'était
astronomiquement c'est fini ça il y a il
y a plus le coût le seul coût nous qu'on
a c'est la matière risque des salair
donc on peut aujourd'hui faire
l'information euh beaucoup plus libre
grâce à ça après euh voilà je trouve que
ça nous donne quand même une agileté une
possibilité de faire des choses bien
quoi.
Je suis entièrement d'accord avec toi d'
et donc on peut être financé par le
peuple sans que ça coûte enfin tu vois
voilà 20000 donateurs sur 65 millions de
personnes, c'est pas la mort. On va y
arriver. Nous on en a 40000 demain c'est
champagne hein. 40000 donateurs sur 65
millions. On ouvre le champagne.
L'alcool avec modération.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu as trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté
pendant je vais te laisser une seconde
pour réfléchir. Soutenez-nous sur Tipi
si vous appréciez notre travail et que
vous avez un peu d'affection pour nous
et que vous souhaitez qu'on continue à
recevoir des gens de gauche, de droite,
des gens qui des emmerdeurs, pas des
emmerdeurs, on a besoin de votre
soutien, c'est très important. Et tu as
trouvé tes bouquins ? Euh non. Alors tu
m'as posé cette question, j'ai pas
tellement de bouquins en tête. Je suis
un peu je suis un peu fatigué explosé de
fatigue. Moi ce que je peux dire c'est
que pour pour les pour les enquêtes
qu'on a fait sur la salle guerre
algérienne, j'avais eu 55 bouquins, tout
ce que j'avais trouvé sur l'Algérie.
J'ai lu plein de bouquins qui
concernaient l'information pour faire
l'Élysée et les oligarques contre
l'info. Donc il y a il y a 3 ans. Euh
Jacques Tometel, la FP, les soldats de
l'information. Enfin, j'ai tout lu euh
pas forcément pour tout gober mais pour
m'enrichir de tout ça. Donc il y a des
bouquins sur les censures aux
États-Unis. Enfin, j'ai j'ai plus
d'exemples précis en tête, mais tous ces
bouquins sont top, sont formidables. Il
faut il faut vraiment j'ai envie de dire
un truc aux gens, regardez comment
fonctionne vraiment l'information. Il y
a des gens qui bossent, il y a des gens
bien, il y a des contraintes terribles.
Ils se battent comme des chiens,
certains d'entre eux, pas tout le monde,
mais il y a enfin voilà, dégueulz pas
totalement sur les journalistes quoi. Il
il y a des gens qui essaient de bosser
quoi.
Ouais. Bah écoute euh perte collatérale,
il y a pas assez de bayonnettes
intelligente hein, c'est notre point de
vue hein. Je une dernière question
d'internet. Euh un off investigation sur
Epstein, c'est faisable ou pas
pourinterrogation ? Off investigation
sur la mort de Marlex,
c'est possible comme l'affaire Robert
Boulin.
Alors c'est grave possible, il y a aucun
problème. Epstein s'est même lancé pour
tout vous dire. On est dessus, on entend
en montage. En exclusivité, tu annonces
ça ?
Ouais, on est en montage depuis ce matin
sur Einstein et on a je me suis maté le
le complément d'enquête là hier pour
voir un peu ce que faisaient les les
collègues de France 2. Donc c'est
intéressant de voir ce que font les
autres quand on prépare un truc. Donc
ouais, on est sur Epstein. Voilà, ça
sera fini dans un mois, un mois et demi,
soit on le balance juste avant l'été,
soit juste après. Euh Boulin, enfin dire
Marlex, DNS, j'ai vu que beaucoup de
gens se posent la question.
Nous ce qu'on a su il y a quelques mois
c'est qu'à priori non seulement Marlex
est mort DNS est mort mais il y a aussi
apparemment deux mecs de la DGSI qui
sont morts de manière un peu étonnante
alors qu'ils avaient bossé sur le
dossier Alstom. Donc je sais rien ce que
ça veut dire.
Tu parles de suicide dans les locaux
avec leur arme de service.
Je sais pas. J'ai pas j'ai pas bossé. Je
je je sais que j'ai commencé à voir
trois quatre personnes liées à la ferom
qui sont morts. Alors encore une fois ça
peut être ouais ça peut être des
suicides. C'est pour ça. Enfin moi
j'aime pas le complotisme du tout mais
puis j'ai pas bossé donc je vais rien
dire en fait. Mais clairement, c'est
vrai que
voilà ce genre de truc, tu as envie de
te dire tiens, c'est quand même
intéressant. Bon Marlex, il a quand même
pointé l'éventualité d'un pacte de
corruption Macronis dans l'affaire stop.
C'est quand même un [__] de sujet.
Bon, il est peut-être mort, suicidé, moi
j'en sais rien. Ce qu'on m'a dit, c'est
que la famille de de DNS apparemment est
beaucoup plus enfin croit pas trop à la
teste du suicide. Donc il faudrait aller
voir. Je crois que le frère de Marlex
est remonté aussi un peu. Il a parlé
chez Lancelin peut-être chez vous. Donc
ouais, il y aurait un sujet possible.
Après oui, tout ça c'est des suers
sujets. Nous, on a envie de faire plein
de trucs et on est assez libre. Le seul
truc que j'ai envie de dire aux gens,
c'est c'est la c'est la caillasse, quoi.
C'estàd qu'à un moment donné, on peut
faire des docs à 40 50000 €. C'est pas
beaucoup en fait. Ça peut paraître
bizarre parce que des fois les médias
indépendants, ils font pour 1500 balles,
mais nous on met un peu plus de moyens
et on met 6 ou 8 mois pour les faire.
Donc ça ça coûte du salaire. Euh mais
pour ça, il faut que les gens se
mobilisent. Donc franchement, c'est open
bar quoi. L'autoroute est ouverte,
allez-y, aidez-nous. Mais on on fait du
doc investigation indépendant. Euh, on n
pas beaucoup à faire ça, donc allez-y
quoi.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur internet. [__] mais
euh
restez libre ou devenez-le. C'est-à-dire
rester libre, ça veut dire faites-vous
confiance, croyez en ce que vous croyez,
allez-y, suivez vos intuitions et en
même temps, pensez contre vous-même.
Soyez les avocats de la partie adverse.
Doutez de vos certitudes. [__] mais
doutez de vos certitudes, quoi.
Questionner vos certitudes du matin au
soir. Cherchez à recouper, vérifier.
Votre cerveau a envie de croire des
trucs tout le temps. On s'accroche. Ça
ça m'arrangerait de croire ça. Ça m'
règlerait le problème. Je pourrais aller
manger une glace. Oui, mais c'est
confortable. Mais est-ce que c'est vrai
? que faut être vraiment dans une
exigence intellectuelle la maximum
possible euh et après se faire confiance
et et surtout je pense que nous les gens
investtigation on a un peu des névrosés
psychiques. Je te fais cours. Ça me
frappe aussi beaucoup de la part d'un
pote qui s'appelle
Jean-Pierre. Enfin,
je pense qu'on est des gens qui avons
été un peu traumatisés par des
soit des mensonges d'enfance, soit qu'
avons eu le sentiment parfois de se
faire un peu enfler et que ça nous a un
peu vacciné. Donc on est des gens qui
aimont pas du tout les intox et c'est
une qualité professionnelle. Donc, j'ai
envie de dire aux jeunes, bah ouais,
méfiez-vous des intox, vérifiez tout,
soyez exigeants et surtout dès que
quelqu'un veut vous dire ce qu'il faut
faire, soyez un peu rebelle quoi hein.
Comme disait mon pote du can enchaîné
Nobili,
parfois [grognement] c'est un peu de
l'acheter dans la presse française. Donc
un peu de rébellion, ça fait du bien. Et
malheureusement, parfois quand on se
rebelle, ben on perd son taf quoi.
Jean-Baptiste Rard, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]